I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. You took me by the hand, made me a man. That one night, you made everything alright. Oh, that one night, baby, that one night. I have tears in my eyes because I am so excited. You know what that song means. That means it's time for a dinner party. Oh my gosh, I'm so excited. You and I watched this episode so many times over and over this week. And
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》的女士们。你牵着我的手，让我成为男人。那一夜，你让一切都好起来。哦，那一夜，宝贝，那一夜。我热泪盈眶，因为我太兴奋了。你知道那首歌意味着什么。那意味着是时候举办晚宴了。天哪，我太兴奋了。你和我这周看了好多次这一集。而且
I'm telling you, I loved it every single time. Angela, my husband Lee had never seen this episode. How is that possible? That is crazy. I got to watch it with a person who's never seen it. I thought he was going to choke. He was laughing so hard, especially during the condo tour. He couldn't catch his breath. Well, my whole family had to watch it over and over. Each one of them watched it with me once. Guys, it is season four, episode 13, written by Gene Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg, directed by Paul Feig, arguably, maybe, the best episode of The Office. Definitely one of the most memorable. Every time Gene and I are, you know, doing interviews or talking about the show, this is an episode we are
我告诉你，我每次看都非常喜欢。安吉拉，我丈夫李以前从没看过这一集。这怎么可能？太疯狂了。我竟然能和一个从没看过的人一起看。我以为他会笑岔气。他笑得太厉害了，尤其是在参观公寓的时候。他都喘不过气来了。好吧，我全家人不得不一遍又一遍地看。他们每个人都和我一起看了一次。伙计们，这是第四季第13集，由吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格编剧，保罗·费格执导，可以说是《办公室》最好的一集。绝对是最令人难忘的一集之一。每次吉恩和我，你知道，在接受采访或谈论这部剧时，这一集总是我们
always asked about. I feel so honored that I got to be at that awkward dinner table. What a great lifelong memory. And we have some really special things for you today. Starting with the summary. I'm not reading the summary today, Angela. Oh no, no, no, no. You know who needs to read the summary. The host of the dinner party himself, Mr. Steve Carell. You are cordially invited to Michael and Jan's condo for a last minute couples only dinner party. Attendance is limited. We only have six wine glasses. Join Jim and Pam, Angela and Andy, and eventually Dwight and his former babysitter for an evening of drinks, games, drink, candles, ossobuco and a home tour like no other. Snip, snap, snip, snap. Let's get
被问到的。我感到非常荣幸能坐在那张尴尬的餐桌旁。多么美好的终身回忆。今天我们为你准备了一些特别的东西。从摘要开始。安吉拉，今天我不读摘要。哦，不，不，不，不。你知道谁需要读摘要。晚宴的主人本人，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔先生。诚挚邀请您参加迈克尔和简的公寓举办的仅限情侣参加的临时晚宴。名额有限。我们只有六个酒杯。加入吉姆和帕姆、安吉拉和安迪，以及最终的德怀特和他的前保姆，享受一个充满美酒、游戏、蜡烛、炖牛膝和独一无二的家庭参观之夜。咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓，咔嚓。让我们开始吧。
to it. Yeah. Thank you, Steve Carell for reading our summary. So guys, we were a little nervous about this one because it is such a big episode. We wanted to really do a good job. And there is so much to cover. So, Gene and I reached out to all of the guests of the dinner party and also to our writers and our director Paul Feig. And everyone is sending in audio clips. Let's get started. Fast fact number one, this episode was written by Gene Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg. I spoke with both of them, Angela. Gene told me that the inspiration for this episode was the Edward Albee play Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf. Now, if you guys don't know this play, it is amazing. And it is about a crazy older married couple
是的。感谢史蒂夫·卡瑞尔朗读我们的摘要。伙计们，我们对这一集有点紧张，因为它太重要了。我们真的想把它做好。而且要涵盖的内容太多了。所以，吉恩和我联系了晚宴的所有嘉宾，还有我们的编剧和导演保罗·费格。每个人都发来了音频片段。让我们开始吧。速记事实一，这一集是由吉恩·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格编写的。安吉拉，我和他们俩都谈过了。吉恩告诉我，这一集的灵感来自爱德华·阿尔比的戏剧《谁害怕弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫》。现在，如果你们不知道这部戏，它非常棒。它是关于一对疯狂的老年已婚夫妇
who invites a younger couple from their work over for a dinner party. And it's just this insane evening. It completely goes off the rails. There's a movie version starring Elizabeth Taylor and Richard Burton. That is crazy good. You can check it out. If you liked this episode, you'll like that movie. Here's a little fun fact from Lee Eisenberg. The original working title for this episode was Who's Afraid of Jan Levinson Gould. Which makes total sense to me because Jan Levinson Gould really brings it. She scared the bejesus out of me in this episode. There are a few moments where she looks at Pam where I was like, I would not want to be Pam today.
邀请一对来自他们工作的年轻夫妇参加晚宴。这是一个疯狂的夜晚。它完全失控了。有一部由伊丽莎白·泰勒和理查德·伯顿主演的电影版。那真是太棒了。你可以去看看。如果你喜欢这一集，你也会喜欢那部电影。这是李·艾森伯格的一个有趣事实。这一集的原始工作标题是《谁害怕简·莱文森·古尔德》。这对我来说完全说得通，因为简·莱文森·古尔德真的很厉害。她在这一集中把我吓坏了。有几个时刻她看着帕姆，我当时想，我今天可不想成为帕姆。
For sure. Gene told me that they were assigned this script right before the writers went on their summer hiatus in June of 2007. So guys, we would go on this little hiatus every summer and the writers could go off and write episodes. Normally, writers only got one week to write an episode. But because they were on hiatus, they had three weeks to work on this episode. I mean, they only got paid for one. But they said they couldn't put it down. They just kept adding details and details. They used their whole hiatus to write it. I mean, I think it shows. I don't want to change the whole structure of how we do television. Maybe we should all get three weeks for a script just saying.
当然。吉恩告诉我，他们在2007年6月编剧们去暑假之前就被分配了这个剧本。伙计们，我们每年夏天都会去度假，编剧们可以去写剧集。通常，编剧只有一周的时间来写一集。但因为他们在度假，他们有三周的时间来写这一集。我的意思是，他们只拿了一周的钱。但他们说他们放不下。他们不断地添加细节。他们用整个假期来写它。我的意思是，我认为这表现出来了。我不想改变我们制作电视节目的整个结构。也许我们都应该为剧本争取三周的时间，只是说说而已。
So we had a fan question from Megan W. and Meredith H. who want to know what everyone's initial reaction to this episode was when we did the table read. Oh, guys. One of the first people I reached out to was Melora and she responded immediately. Here is Melora's reaction to getting the script. When I read the dinner party episode, I was definitely just blown away. I was on the floor laughing and really felt like it was going to be so much fun. I just couldn't wait to sink my teeth into it. It just felt like, you know, all of the wonderful, unhealthy, and completely dysfunctional elements of Jan and Michael kind of coming to a head. And
所以我们收到了梅根·W和梅雷迪思·H的粉丝提问，她们想知道我们在剧本朗读时对这一集的最初反应是什么。哦，伙计们。我联系的第一批人之一是梅洛拉，她立即回复了。这是梅洛拉对拿到剧本的反应。当我读到晚宴那一集时，我绝对被震撼了。我笑得倒在地上，真的觉得这会非常有趣。我迫不及待地想深入其中。感觉就像，你知道，简和迈克尔所有美妙、不健康且完全功能失调的元素都汇聚在一起了。而且
I couldn't really wait to dive in and get going. Angela Jean told me that during the table read of this, he sweated through his shirt. He said, it started off a little quiet because the episode is pretty dark, but that by the end, when the cop says, not now Dwight, the whole room just erupted into laughter. And afterwards, Gray Daniels came up to him and Lee and said, this script was perfect. Wow. So Jean reminded me that before he and Lee got their jobs on the office, Jean had been working part time as Harold Ramis' nanny and Lee was a temp at HBO. And he just said,
我真的迫不及待地想投入其中并开始工作。安吉拉，吉恩告诉我，在剧本朗读时，他汗流浃背。他说，开始时有点安静，因为这一集相当黑暗，但到最后，当警察说“现在不行，德怀特”时，整个房间都爆发出了笑声。之后，格雷·丹尼尔斯走到他和李面前说，这个剧本太完美了。哇。所以吉恩提醒我，在他和李得到《办公室》的工作之前，吉恩一直在做哈罗德·雷米斯的保姆，而李是HBO的临时工。他只是说，
Greg changed our lives. So hearing from this man who was our mentor telling us we nailed it, it was the highest compliment he ever received as a writer. I bet that means so much to them. You know, Jenna, here's what I remember about this table read. I do remember this build. It started and it just took over the room. People were laughing and then laughing and then really laughing. And by the end, that final line of the script, everyone started applauding. And I remember the applause lasted for like a minute. Yeah.
格雷改变了我们的生活。所以听到这位作为我们导师的人告诉我们我们做到了，这是他作为编剧收到的最高赞美。我敢打赌这对他们意义重大。你知道，珍娜，关于这次剧本朗读，我记得的是。我确实记得这种积累。它开始了，然后就接管了整个房间。人们在笑，然后在大笑，然后是真正的大笑。到最后，剧本的最后一句台词，每个人都开始鼓掌。我记得掌声持续了大约一分钟。是的。
It just felt so amazing for Jean and Lee to see their hard work, just have that kind of adoration in the moment. We'll get this, guys. I guess the folks at NBC did not love this script. Oh, no. After the table read, Greg had a phone call with NBC. Uh-oh. When we asked Rainn Wilson about this episode, he talks about that phone call. Another party. It is one of the top three all-time great office episodes. It's absolutely extraordinary. It's a pretty dark episode. And after the table read, I heard a story from Greg Daniels
对于吉恩和李来说，看到他们的辛勤工作在当下得到那样的崇拜，感觉真是太棒了。伙计们，听着。我想NBC的人并不喜欢这个剧本。哦，不。剧本朗读后，格雷和NBC通了电话。哦哦。当我们问雷恩·威尔逊关于这一集时，他谈到了那个电话。另一个派对。这是有史以来最伟大的《办公室》剧集前三名之一。它绝对是非凡的。这是一个相当黑暗的剧集。剧本朗读后，我从格雷·丹尼尔斯那里听到了一个故事，
that the network was like, um, that's a very dark episode. And Greg was like, yes. Yes, it is. Like, are we sure we want it so dark? And Greg was like, yep. And they were like, okay. And then we proceeded. You know, I feel like if this episode had come earlier in our run, maybe it wouldn't have happened, right? Maybe NBC would have given notes and Greg would have maybe had to sort of pick his battles. But at this point, our show was so established and critically acclaimed and had won awards. I feel like Greg was able to confidently say to them,
电视网说，嗯，那是一个非常黑暗的剧集。格雷说，是的。是的，确实如此。就像，我们确定想要它这么黑暗吗？格雷说，是的。他们说，好吧。然后我们就继续了。你知道，我觉得如果这一集出现在我们剧集的早期，也许就不会发生了，对吧？也许NBC会给出意见，格雷可能不得不选择他的战斗。但在这一点上，我们的节目已经非常成熟，广受好评，并赢得了奖项。我觉得格雷能够自信地对他们说，
like, yeah, this is the show. This is how it's written and we're going to do it. Jean and Lee told me that they did not do a rewrite on the script. Wow. You guys, all of our episodes, as amazing as they were, would go through several rewrites. That's just kind of how a script comes to be. So for this to not have a single rewrite, that is amazing. Yeah. So we had this amazing script. We're all ready to shoot this amazing episode. And then we got shut down because of the writer's strike. Yeah.
就像，是的，这就是这个节目。这就是它的写法，我们要这样做。吉恩和李告诉我，他们没有对剧本进行重写。哇。伙计们，我们所有的剧集，尽管它们很棒，但都经过了几次重写。这就是剧本的诞生方式。所以，没有进行一次重写，这太神奇了。是的。所以我们有了这个很棒的剧本。我们都准备好拍摄这个很棒的剧集了。然后我们因为编剧罢工而停工了。是的。
For four months, we had to wait. It was just a very surreal time because so many shows that shut down did not come back. They weren't able to survive the strike. And the fact that we were able to come back and we knew we had scripts waiting for us was huge. But it was really important for us as a cast that we stand with our writers and support them. Jean and Lee said it was really surreal because they went from writing this episode, having this table read, to picketing their own set. Yeah.
四个月，我们不得不等待。那是一个非常超现实的时期，因为很多停工的节目都没有回来。他们没能从罢工中幸存下来。事实上，我们能够回来，而且我们知道有剧本在等着我们，这意义重大。但对于我们演员来说，与我们的编剧站在一起并支持他们非常重要。吉恩和李说这真的很超现实，因为他们从写这一集、进行剧本朗读，到在他们自己的片场外纠察。是的。
And it was so, so bizarre. But we shut down. This leads me to FastFact number two. FastFact number two is that Paul Feig directed this episode, but he almost did not direct this episode. I couldn't even imagine if it wasn't him. I know. I know. Well, when we reached out to him, he told us how this came about. I had been brought on. I directed a lot of episodes of The Office, but in that season, I had been given Survivor Man, which I was really excited about and actually very, very proud of that episode. But I remember reading the script for the dinner party and it was
这真是太奇怪了。但我们停工了。这引出了速记事实二。速记事实二就是保罗·费格执导了这一集，但他差点没执导这一集。我甚至无法想象如果不是他会怎样。我知道。我知道。好吧，当我们联系他时，他告诉我们这是怎么发生的。我被聘用了。我执导了很多集《办公室》，但在那一季，我被分配了《幸存者》，我对此非常兴奋，实际上对那一集感到非常非常自豪。但我记得读到晚宴的剧本时，它被
given to some other director. And I was so jealous because I thought like, if only I could do this episode, this is like everything I want to do. It's so uncomfortable and cringy and hilarious. But another director was assigned to it. But then the writer strike happened. And so it all fell apart because I did Survivor Man. Then the writer strike stopped everything. And so we were off for months and months and months for however long the registry went. And my great joy was at the end of that, everything shifted so much that that director who was supposed to do the dinner party wasn't able to. And so it came back around to me.
给了另一位导演。我非常嫉妒，因为我想，如果我能执导这一集就好了，这简直是我想要做的一切。它太不舒服、太尴尬、太搞笑了。但另一位导演被分配给了它。但后来编剧罢工发生了。所以一切都分崩离析了。因为我做了《幸存者》。然后编剧罢工停止了一切。所以我们休息了几个月又几个月，无论注册表持续了多久。我最大的快乐是，在那之后，一切都发生了很大的变化，那个本该执导晚宴的导演没能做到。所以它又回到了我这里。
And so I was so excited to do that episode. I just saw it so clearly in my head. And it was just so funny to me. But the crazy thing about that episode was once we did it, we knew it was so funny. The audience, the loyal office audiences hated it. It was really a very divisive episode because I think it was so uncomfortable and so cringy that people couldn't deal with it. And I remember like we were so excited, all of us, all the writers, everybody, we were so excited because we really thought this was kind of like one of the best things this show could do. And we were kind of all bummed out that people were so weird about it. But
所以我非常兴奋能执导那一集。我在脑海中清晰地看到了它。对我来说，它太搞笑了。但那一集疯狂的事情是，一旦我们拍完，我们就知道它太搞笑了。忠实的《办公室》观众讨厌它。这确实是一个非常两极分化的剧集，因为我认为它太不舒服、太尴尬了，人们无法接受。我记得我们都很兴奋，我们所有的编剧，每个人，我们都很兴奋，因为我们真的认为这可能是这个节目能做的最好的事情之一。我们都对人们对它的奇怪反应感到沮丧。但是
I think the whole thing was it was so uncomfortable. The first time you watch it, you almost can't handle it. But once you watch it, a second and third and fourth and however many times you watch it, then it becomes fun because you know it's coming. You know it's going to be terrible and you just can enjoy the cringiness. And so I could not be prouder of that episode. It's really, you know, I want a DGA directing award for it, which is the only time I'll ever get an award for anything. But I just think it's the funniest thing in the world. I remember the fan response to this episode was not overwhelmingly positive when this
我认为整件事就是它太不舒服了。你第一次看的时候，几乎无法承受。但一旦你看了第二遍、第三遍、第四遍，无论你看多少遍，它就会变得有趣，因为你知道接下来会发生什么。你知道它会很糟糕，你只需要享受那种尴尬。所以我对那一集感到无比自豪。它真的，你知道，我为此赢得了DGA导演奖，这是我唯一一次获得任何奖项。但我只是认为它是世界上最有趣的事情。我记得当这一集
show first aired. Yeah, I remember even within my own extended family, they either loved it or they hated it. Yes, very strong reactions. It has grown to be beloved. It was not beloved when it first aired. You know, I don't know who this other director was that was supposed to direct this episode. But Jean told me that this person had never directed a single camera comedy ever, that this episode would have been their first one. Oh my Lord. Now, maybe it was a big time movie person, you know, and they just never done half hour TV before. I am so glad that we got Paul Feig. Yeah, I mean, you don't want the dinner party script to be your first time at single camera comedy. If I were that person, I wouldn't sleep.
首次播出时，粉丝的反应并不是压倒性的积极。是的，我记得即使在我自己的大家庭里，他们要么喜欢它，要么讨厌它。是的，反应非常强烈。它已经成长为备受喜爱。它在首次播出时并不受欢迎。你知道，我不知道这个本该执导这一集的其他导演是谁。但吉恩告诉我，这个人从来没有执导过单机位喜剧，这一集将是他们的第一集。天哪。现在，也许他是一个大牌电影人，你知道，他们以前从未做过半小时的电视节目。我很高兴我们得到了保罗·费格。是的，我的意思是，你不想让晚宴剧本成为你第一次尝试单机位喜剧。如果我是那个人，我睡不着觉。
Yeah. No. Fast act number three, Angela, we know that the writer strike provided us with Paul Feig. It also provided us with a problem in the form of your giant belly. I was wondering when you're going to bring that up. I'm not the only person bringing up your belly, Angela, because when we asked Paul Feig about his memories of shooting this episode, he discussed it. Oh, no. One of my favorites is how we had to desperately hide Angela's pregnancy during it because she was very late late stages. And so you'll notice a lot of her carrying flowers and things in the foreground and then a pillow on her lap and she's sitting on the couch. I think
是的。不。速记事实三，安吉拉，我们知道编剧罢工为我们提供了保罗·费格。它也以你巨大的肚子形式为我们提供了一个问题。我一直在想你什么时候会提起这件事。安吉拉，我不是唯一一个提起你肚子的人，因为当我们问保罗·费格关于拍摄这一集的记忆时，他讨论了它。哦，不。我最喜欢的事情之一是我们是如何拼命隐藏安吉拉的怀孕的，因为她当时处于非常晚的阶段。所以你会注意到她经常在前景中拿着花之类的东西，然后膝盖上放着一个枕头，她坐在沙发上。我想
we had her in a big giant overcoat too. So so that was fun. It was very challenging doing special effects with those special effects. So Angela, we also got mail about your belly from Susie S, Alex G, and Emma O. Oh no, ladies. They want to know how far along were you in your pregnancy and what kind of meeting was there for hiding Angela's baby bump in this episode? Please tell us everything. Well, ladies, if memory serves me, we filmed this episode in early March. Now you have to remember when we did the deposition, I was barely showing. Four months have gone by into my pregnancy. I had my baby early May. So it was a belly. It was a full on a baby belly. And I do remember
我们还让她穿了一件巨大的大衣。所以这很有趣。用那些特效做特效非常具有挑战性。所以安吉拉，我们也收到了关于你肚子的邮件，来自苏西·S、亚历克斯·G和艾玛·O。哦，不，女士们。她们想知道你怀孕多久了，在这一集中隐藏安吉拉的孕肚有什么样的会议？请告诉我们一切。好吧，女士们，如果记忆没出错的话，我们在三月初拍摄了这一集。现在你必须记住，当我们做证词时，我几乎看不出来。我怀孕四个月了。我在五月初生了孩子。所以那是一个肚子。那是一个完全的婴儿肚。我确实记得
poor Paul Feig. He's the sweetest person coming up to me and being like, Hey, Angela, so we're going to have you stand behind the copier. We're going to have you hold this bill. We're going to have you hold a purse. We're going to have flowers. We're going to have a wall you stand behind. There were like all of these things. There were actual meetings about how to hide my belly. And then when we started filming, I remember tucking behind the copier and Matt Sohn, our camera operator, saying, I can still see a dange. I was like, what? So now there was this new dialogue I had with the camera operators where they'd be like, back it up a little, pivot, pivot, like duck, hold it higher. We had this whole language
可怜的保罗·费格。他是最贴心的人，走到我面前说，嘿，安吉拉，我们要让你站在复印机后面。我们要让你拿着这张账单。我们要让你拿着钱包。我们要有花。我们要有一堵墙让你站在后面。有所有这些事情。关于如何隐藏我的肚子，甚至有实际的会议。然后当我们开始拍摄时，我记得躲在复印机后面，我们的摄像师马特·索恩说，我还是能看到一点。我说，什么？所以现在我和摄像师之间有了这种新的对话，他们会说，往后退一点，旋转，旋转，像蹲下，举高点。我们有整套语言
of the belly hide. Am I correct that in that scene when you first enter the condo and Michael and Jan are trying to take your coats, you don't take off your coat because you needed it to hide your belly? Oh, yeah. And my coat was enormous. It's like not a coat I would ever wear. It was so big. But yeah, I have a lot of track the belly moments for this episode that I can sprinkle in as we go. But we had to get creative. It was a big belly. One day, no belly. Next day, big belly. That's what happened during the writer's strike. Well, guys, those are my fast facts. I think we should take a break and we will be back
关于隐藏肚子。我说的对吗，在你们第一次进入公寓，迈克尔和简试图拿走你们的外套的那一幕中，你没有脱掉外套，因为你需要它来隐藏你的肚子？哦，是的。我的外套非常大。这不是我会穿的外套。它太大了。但是的，对于这一集，我有很多追踪肚子的时刻，我可以在我们进行时穿插进去。但我们必须发挥创造力。那是一个大肚子。有一天，没有肚子。第二天，大肚子。这就是编剧罢工期间发生的事情。好吧，伙计们，这就是我的速记事实。我想我们应该休息一下，我们会回来的
with a dinner party and more audio clips from our dinner guests. Light your candles. Get your Osobuko going. We're about to have a dinner party. We are back. We are at the office. It's a Friday night. We're working late. Oh, there's a special assignment from corporate, which we never find out what the special assignment is like really and truly how creative did Michael Scott have to get that he was able to con the whole bullpen? Yeah, everyone's shuffling papers. They're looking at things. What are we doing? What do we think the assignment is? It seems like we're doing stuff. I feel like this is Michael's smartest moment that he came up with a special assignment that
带着晚宴和更多来自我们晚餐客人的音频片段。点亮你的蜡烛。准备好你的炖牛膝。我们要举办晚宴了。我们回来了。我们在办公室。这是一个周五晚上。我们加班。哦，公司有一个特别任务，我们从来不知道特别任务是什么，真的，迈克尔·斯科特必须有多大的创造力才能骗过整个办公室？是的，每个人都在洗牌。他们在看东西。我们在做什么？我们认为任务是什么？看起来我们在做事情。我觉得这是迈克尔最聪明的时刻，他想出了一个特别任务，
everyone believed. Yeah. At 36 seconds, Jenna, is when Jim knows. I believe this is when Jim knows because Michael gets on the phone to corporate and he's like, it's not fair to these people. These people are my friends and I care about them. Who talks like that to corporate? I know Jim knows, but people are grumbling. They're griping and there is a great deleted scene. It's a whole runner with Toby. Toby is sharing that he's so bummed out because he had tickets to Tom Petty. What? Yeah. And Toby had to give them to his ex-wife and her new boyfriend. Oh, no. So yeah, everyone is kind of like, they're bummed out. Why are they staying so late? And then Michael proudly walks in because he's had this phone call
每个人都相信了。是的。珍娜，在36秒时，吉姆知道了。我相信这就是吉姆知道的时候，因为迈克尔给公司打电话，他说，这对这些人不公平。这些人是我的朋友，我关心他们。谁会那样对公司说话？我知道吉姆知道，但人们在抱怨。他们在发牢骚，有一个很棒的删减场景。这是关于托比的整个情节。托比分享说他很沮丧，因为他有汤姆·佩蒂的票。什么？是的。托比不得不把它们给他的前妻和她的新男友。哦，不。所以是的，每个人都有点，他们很沮丧。为什么他们要待这么晚？然后迈克尔自豪地走进来，因为他打了那个电话
and he's like, you know what? You don't have to stay late. I told corporate we're not doing it. Everyone can go home and they're like, wow, thank you, Michael. Yeah. And then he turns to Jim and he says, hey, you want to come have dinner at our place tonight? I know you have no plans. Oh, and Jim's like, he got me. Yep. Yeah. Well, there's a series of deleted talking heads where people talk about their ideal dinner party. And there's one by Michael Scott that really cracked me up. Sam, can we play that? My ideal dinner party. Easy. Jim Pam, Ryan, the mayor, Barack Obama, Shiloh Jolie Pitt, because at the end of the night, Brad or Angelina would have to come and pick them up. And I would get
他说，你知道吗？你们不必待得太晚。我告诉公司我们不做了。每个人都可以回家了，他们说，哇，谢谢你，迈克尔。是的。然后他转向吉姆说，嘿，你今晚想来我们家吃晚饭吗？我知道你没有计划。哦，吉姆说，他抓住了我。是的。是的。好吧，有一系列删减的谈话头，人们谈论他们理想的晚宴。迈克尔·斯科特有一个让我大笑的谈话头。萨姆，我们可以播放那个吗？我理想的晚宴。简单。吉姆、帕姆、瑞安、市长、巴拉克·奥巴马、希洛·朱莉·皮特，因为在晚上结束时，布拉德或安吉丽娜必须来接他们。我会
to meet them. Shiloh beef, because of Disturbia. All of the children of the world. Val Kilmer, but he probably wouldn't come too famous. Obviously, George Clooney and Jan definitely if there was room. Michael would invite all of the children of the world. Val Kilmer. Probably George Clooney, but only Jan if there was room. Oh, that tells you everything you need to know. Right. And I feel like they deleted that because it was tipping his hand too soon. Right. Well, now we have a very sad talking head from Dwight that ends with just crying. He's so sad he hasn't been invited. Yeah. I thought rain was so funny in this talking head. He really made me laugh. Bless his heart. All right, lady. It's time to go
见到他们。希洛·比夫，因为《后窗惊魂》。全世界所有的孩子。瓦尔·基尔默，但他可能不会来，太出名了。显然，乔治·克鲁尼，如果还有空间的话，简肯定会来。迈克尔会邀请全世界所有的孩子。瓦尔·基尔默。可能还有乔治·克鲁尼，但如果还有空间的话，只有简。哦，这告诉你所有你需要知道的事情。对。我觉得他们删掉了那个，因为它太早暴露了他的意图。对。好吧，现在我们有一个来自德怀特的非常悲伤的谈话头，最后只是哭泣。他很伤心，因为他没有被邀请。是的。我觉得雷恩在这个谈话头里太搞笑了。他真的让我笑了。保佑他的心。好了，女士。是时候去
to the condo. All right. So Pam and Jim arrived to the condo. It's already awkward. And this is going to be a comedy sprint to the end. It's just going to be one joke after the next. Well, it starts with both Michael and Jan trying to hug Jim at the same time. And then I don't know if you noticed, but only Michael hugs Pam. Jan does not even go in for a hug. Oh, I noticed. And then she throws you some serious shade about the wine you brought. She's like, oh, thank you so much. This will be great to cook with, which you guys know is code for thanks for the crappy wine. Exactly. Angela Jean told me that one of their goals in this episode was that it would just be loaded with a ton of subtle passive aggressive
公寓了。好吧。所以帕姆和吉姆到达了公寓。这已经很尴尬了。这将是一场喜剧冲刺到最后。这只是一个接一个的笑话。好吧，它始于迈克尔和简同时试图拥抱吉姆。然后我不知道你是否注意到了，但只有迈克尔拥抱了帕姆。简甚至没有去拥抱。哦，我注意到了。然后她对你带来的酒说了一些严重的刻薄话。她说，哦，非常感谢。这用来烹饪会很棒，你们知道这是代码，意思是谢谢你带来的烂酒。正是如此。安吉拉，吉恩告诉我，他们在这一集中的目标之一是它应该充满大量的微妙的被动攻击
comments and coded language. And that this dig at Pam about the wine was the first. Jean also told me that this moment was inspired by the fact that he and Lee were roommates when they first started writing on the show and that Lee Eisenberg is an amazing cook. He referred to him as a gormon. What? Yeah. And one time Jean saw Lee cooking with some wine, which was something that Jean did not know you could do. His actual words were, it blew my mind. He's such a dude. Of course you can cook with wine. Well, I guess Lee explained to him that it has to be a cheap wine and that always stuck in his head that you cook with cheap wine. And that's why he gave that line to Jan. Well, it's perfect.
评论和编码语言。而这个关于酒对帕姆的挖苦是第一个。吉恩还告诉我，这个时刻的灵感来自于他和李刚开始写这个节目时是室友，而李·艾森伯格是一位出色的厨师。他称他为美食家。什么？是的。有一次吉恩看到李用一些酒做饭，这是吉恩不知道你可以做的事情。他的原话是，这让我大开眼界。他真是个家伙。当然你可以用酒做饭。好吧，我想李向他解释说它必须是便宜的酒，这总是留在他的脑海里，你用便宜的酒做饭。这就是为什么他把那句台词给了简。好吧，这很完美。
Babe, should we take a tour, babe? Yeah, babe. Oh, I'm so sorry about this horrendous carpet. We're a work in progress. I call this the mask wall, babe. Oh, we watch this episode a lot, but it's so good. This home tour really kicks off all of the Jan and Michael dynamics in this episode. And when we asked John Krasinski about his memories of this episode, he talked about this scene of Jim and Pam arriving and then starting the tour. That episode was without a doubt one of my favorite to ever shoot because there was this incredible energy on set, this idea that we were finally getting to pull the curtain back on the world of Michael Scott. And I think that for me, I was already almost laughing in every scene because of how Steve
宝贝，我们要参观一下吗，宝贝？是的，宝贝。哦，我很抱歉这块可怕的地毯。我们还在进行中。我称这为面具墙，宝贝。哦，我们看了很多次这一集，但它太好了。这次家庭参观真正开启了这一集中所有的简和迈克尔的动态。当我们问约翰·卡拉辛斯基关于这一集的记忆时，他谈到了吉姆和帕姆到达然后开始参观的场景。那一集毫无疑问是我拍摄过的最喜欢的剧集之一，因为片场有一种令人难以置信的能量，这种想法是我们终于要揭开迈克尔·斯科特世界的帷幕。而且我认为对我来说，我几乎在每一场戏里都在笑，因为史蒂夫
was playing his character. There was this unbelievable beaming of pride and joy to have these two people finally in his home after what I imagined to be a lifetime of hoping and wishing that it could be possible one day. And here they were. And not only were they in his home, he was able to give them a tour. And then the battling dichotomy of Michael's excitement and Jan's sort of weighty judgment of his house and his excitement was all loaded into every scene. It's so true. So true. So well said, JK. We got a fan question, Angela, from Cameron W. Linda M. and Monica J. Did you guys actually film in someone's house? Oh, yeah. There was a man that owned this condo. Yeah. It was
是如何扮演他的角色的。有一种令人难以置信的自豪和喜悦，让这两个人终于在他的家里，在我想象中，他一生都在希望和祈祷有一天能成为可能。他们就在这里。不仅他们在他的家里，他还能带他们参观。然后迈克尔的兴奋和简对他房子的那种沉重的评判以及他的兴奋之间的战斗二分法被加载到每一场戏中。太真实了。太真实了。说得太好了，JK。安吉拉，我们收到了卡梅伦·W、琳达·M和莫妮卡·J的粉丝提问。你们真的在别人的房子里拍摄吗？哦，是的。有一个人拥有这个公寓。是的。它是
a condo in Woodland Hills, California. And I remember they told me they had to take out all of that man's furniture and repaint his walls. And then they had to put it all back the way he had it. And that blew my mind. I know. In the deposition DVD commentary, Ed talked about this for a minute. He said when they filmed in the garage, this man's belongings, there were some of them that they just shoved all into one corner. And they were like, what is this guy about? Because guess what he had? What? He had all of these professional ping pong player posters. What? Yes. And they had just had all this ping pong in the deposition. So they were like, oh my gosh. And they recognize some of the names
加利福尼亚州伍德兰希尔斯的一个公寓。我记得他们告诉我，他们不得不搬走那个人的所有家具，并重新粉刷他的墙壁。然后他们不得不把一切都放回他原来的样子。这让我大开眼界。我知道。在证词DVD评论中，埃德谈到了这一点。他说当他们在车库拍摄时，这个人的财物，有些他们只是把它们全部塞进一个角落。他们就像，这家伙是干什么的？因为猜猜他有什么？什么？他有所有这些职业乒乓球运动员的海报。什么？是的。他们刚刚在证词中有了所有这些乒乓球。所以他们就像，天哪。他们认出了一些名字
because of Dwight's talking head. And he said, in addition to all the professional ping pong posters, he had a professional ping pong table that was folded up and sort of wedged in the corner. Wow. So this guy obviously was a ping pong enthusiast. We know that. Maybe he was an amateur, uprising professional ping pong player. Maybe he was a champion. We don't know. We don't know. But yes, he had to move all of his stuff out and cram a bunch of stuff into the corner of the garage. And then we had to put it all back for him. Well, we asked Paul Feig about designing the condo for Michael and Jan. And here is what he had to say. For Michael and Jan's condo, I had had the benefit of being the person, the director
因为德怀特的谈话头。他说，除了所有的职业乒乓球海报，他还有一个折叠起来并塞在角落里的专业乒乓球桌。哇。所以这家伙显然是一个乒乓球爱好者。我们知道这一点。也许他是一个业余的、正在崛起的职业乒乓球运动员。也许他是一个冠军。我们不知道。我们不知道。但是的，他不得不搬走他所有的东西，并把一堆东西塞进车库的角落。然后我们不得不为他把一切都放回去。好吧，我们问保罗·费格关于为迈克尔和简设计公寓的事。这是他不得不说的。对于迈克尔和简的公寓，我有幸成为那个人，导演
who got to do Office Olympics, which was where we established Michael and Jan's condo when he bought it. And so, you know, found this very kind of stark, normal, cookie cutter kind of condo that he would have with very stark white walls and all that. And that was really fun. So when I was lucky enough to get to do this episode and go back to there, the whole concept of what Jan would have done with that place was really fun to play with. And I remember Lee and Jean and I got really hung up on the idea that she had a warhol. I think they even put it into the script, but that she had done it like a warhol-esque print of herself. Would you only see briefly when they're in the hallway? I think when
谁做了《办公室奥运会》，那是我们建立迈克尔和简的公寓的地方，当他买下它时。所以，你知道，找到了这种非常刻板、普通、千篇一律的公寓，他会有非常刻板的白墙等等。这真的很有趣。所以当我幸运地得到这一集并回到那里时，简会对那个地方做什么的整个概念真的很有趣。我记得李、吉恩和我对她有一个沃霍尔的想法非常纠结。我想他们甚至把它写进了剧本，但她做了一个像沃霍尔风格的她自己的印刷品。你只会当他们在走廊时短暂地看到它？我想当
Jim and Pam first arrive, and you see it in the stairwell when they go up to the infamous candle room, and it's like this quad warhol-style picture of Jan. But I just love the idea that we had to show off how Jan had fixed up the place, but also the idea that Jan had done it. Even though she tried to warm it up, it was kind of very cold. So we were hung up on the idea of like really like dark gray walls and what art she would have put up. And I was very, very hung up on the idea of them putting up a, that Jan put up a kimono on the wall, which I had seen somewhere and thought, oh, that's kind of a cool decoration, but it's also not terribly warm at the same time. And so that made me laugh.
吉姆和帕姆第一次到达时，你在楼梯间看到它，当他们去那个臭名昭著的蜡烛房时，它就像那个简的四联沃霍尔风格的照片。但我只是喜欢我们必须炫耀简是如何整理这个地方的想法，但也喜欢简做了这件事的想法。即使她试图让它变暖，它也相当冷。所以我们纠结于像非常深灰色的墙壁以及她会挂什么艺术品的想法。我非常非常纠结于他们挂上一个，简挂上一个和服在墙上的想法，我在某个地方看到过，觉得，哦，那是一个很酷的装饰，但同时也不是特别温暖。所以这让我笑了。
I have to add another little tidbit, Angela, is that I guess they put up a bunch of photos. You can't really tell when you're watching, but they are all photos of Jan and other men. There are no photos of Jan and Michael. And then there's a lot of photos I remember of just Jan by herself. Yes. Like in a frame. Like she has made it the Jan shrine. But I love that she has given it her touch, but it's in no way homey. No, it's just really kind of cold. And Michael has no space that is his own, except maybe where all of his rejected furniture items have gone into the garage. Yeah, they take Pam and Jim on this tour. And we learned that Jan has both an office space and a workspace because she can't
我必须补充另一个小花絮，安吉拉，我想他们挂了一堆照片。当你观看时你真的看不出来，但它们都是简和其他男人的照片。没有简和迈克尔的照片。然后我记得有很多简独自一人的照片。是的。像在相框里。就像她把它变成了简的神殿。但我喜欢她给了它她的触感，但它绝不是温馨的。不，它只是真的相当冷。迈克尔没有任何属于他自己的空间，除了也许他所有被拒绝的家具都去了车库。是的，他们带帕姆和吉姆参观。我们了解到简既有一个办公空间又有一个工作空间，因为她不能
create in her office space. And her desk in her office space looked like no one had ever sat there. It's so sparse. Oh, at three minutes, 32 seconds, you can see that her desk chair still has the plastic cover on the arms. Oh my gosh, fantastic. That was a little detail that Paul Feig had. He thought that would be funny. So he made them leave it on. That's great. They put so much thought into every little nook and cranny of that condo. Should we talk about the candle room? Yes. I can't imagine what that smelled like. It must have been so strong. Oh, lady, we got a lot of mail about it from Ross C Sierra S Ali E and Emily D did the candle room actually smell like candles. Oh, yeah. It was a room full of multiple
在她的办公空间里创作。她的办公桌在她的办公空间里看起来就像从来没有人坐在那里。它太稀疏了。哦，在三分钟32秒时，你可以看到她的办公椅扶手上还有塑料盖。天哪，太棒了。那是保罗·费格的一个小细节。他认为那会很有趣。所以他让他们留着它。太棒了。他们对那个公寓的每一个小角落都投入了这么多心思。我们应该谈谈蜡烛房吗？是的。我无法想象那闻起来像什么。它一定非常强烈。哦，女士，我们收到了很多关于它的邮件，来自罗斯·C、塞拉·S、阿里·E和艾米丽·D，蜡烛房真的闻起来像蜡烛吗？哦，是的。那是一个装满了多个
scented candles. Well, I didn't have to go in the candle room. And thank goodness, because I was pregnant and so sensitive to smell, I probably would have been like, but Paul Feig spoke about the candle room. And here's the audio clip. The candle room. We just knew that we wanted the candle room to be insane. And the big thing was like, when you're in there, it smelled crazy. And it's like, how do we do that? How do we put that across to an audience? Because one thing an audience can't take in the two things they can't take in the temperature of what's happening and they can't take in the smell that was happening. And so that's where you have that shot of John Krasinski, like kind of like looking
香薰蜡烛的房间。好吧，我不需要去蜡烛房。谢天谢地，因为我怀孕了，对气味非常敏感，我可能就像，但保罗·费格谈到了蜡烛房。这是音频片段。蜡烛房。我们只是知道我们想要蜡烛房是疯狂的。大事情是，当你身处其中时，它闻起来很疯狂。就像，我们怎么做呢？我们怎么把它传达给观众？因为观众无法接受的一件事，他们无法接受的两件事是正在发生的事情的温度，他们无法接受正在发生的气味。所以这就是为什么你有那个约翰·卡拉辛斯基的镜头，像那种看着
at the door and like, oh, like he can't breathe because you just know it just stinks in there. But I really just loved how dense and terrible we made that room. I loved John's look to camera when he was gasping for air. It was so believable and funny. And I don't think that was probably an easy thing to convey, but he did it so well. So well. John and I talked with Paul before we shot that scene and he said, I want it to look like you guys are doing that thing when you walk into a stinky public restroom and you've taken like a deep breath before you walk in, you're trying to hold it for as long as you can. And then you need air. So you're just trying to take in the smallest amount of air that will get
门，像，哦，像他无法呼吸，因为你知道那里只是臭气熏天。但我真的只是喜欢我们让那个房间变得多么密集和糟糕。我喜欢约翰在气喘吁吁时看向镜头的样子。这太可信和搞笑了。我不认为那可能是一件容易传达的事情，但他做得太好了。太好了。约翰和我谈过保罗，在我们拍摄那场戏之前，他说，我希望它看起来像你们在走进一个臭气熏天的公共厕所时做的那种事情，你在走进去之前深吸了一口气，你试图尽可能长时间地屏住呼吸。然后你需要空气。所以你只是试图吸入最少量的空气，让你
you through. Yeah. So that's what we were trying to do in that scene. Well, now they move into the master bedroom. Oh my gosh, there are so many delicious moments in this. I do not know how you guys got through this. Well, I'm going to say that a lot through this episode because there are scenes that were just the four of you that are some of the funniest scenes I've ever seen. And I don't know how you got through this one. This is the scene where for the longest time, there's just a camera on a tripod pointed at the bed. Yeah. Which Jim and Pam clock immediately and so does the audience. And then Jan says, Michael, I told you to put that away and then she swats him on the butt.
度过难关。是的。所以这就是我们在那场戏中试图做的。好吧，现在他们搬进了主卧室。天哪，这里面有这么多美味的时刻。我不知道你们是怎么度过这一关的。好吧，在这一集中我会说很多次，因为有些场景只是你们四个人，是我见过的一些最有趣的场景。我不知道你是怎么度过这一关的。这是那个场景，很长一段时间里，只有一个三脚架上的摄像机对着床。是的。吉姆和帕姆立即注意到了，观众也注意到了。然后简说，迈克尔，我告诉过你把它收起来，然后她拍了他的屁股。
It's so uncomfortable. She swats him on the butt. Yeah. And then we learned that Michael sleeps on a bench at the foot of the bed. And Angela, I can't even tell you how hard we laughed every time Steve Carell curled up on that bench. He was like, no, I fit. Look, it's actually pretty comfortable. He just curls up like a baby on it. Well, Paul shared with us the inspiration behind the bench. And it's so great. Here it is. So the whole thing with Michael and Jan and that weird bench of these sleeps on the end of the bed came from when I was working as a script reader in the early 80s for a Hollywood, big Hollywood producer. And I befriended this woman who worked in his company. And at one point we
太不舒服了。她拍了他的屁股。是的。然后我们了解到迈克尔睡在床脚的长凳上。安吉拉，我甚至无法告诉你，每次史蒂夫·卡瑞尔蜷缩在那张长凳上时，我们笑得有多厉害。他就像，不，我合适。看，它实际上很舒服。他只是像个婴儿一样蜷缩在上面。好吧，保罗和我们分享了长凳背后的灵感。它太棒了。在这里。所以迈克尔和简以及他睡在床尾的那张奇怪的长凳的整件事来自于我在80年代初作为剧本读者为好莱坞、大好莱坞制片人工作时。我结识了在他公司工作的一位女士。有一次我们
were hanging out and we went by her house to pick something up. And I went into there and they had this open bedroom plan. And I looked and there was this giant bed, like a king size bed, but then next to the bed was this little tiny cot. And I remember saying like, Oh, what's that? And she got very serious. He said, like, look, when you get in a relationship, you have to make sure that you're able to be intimate with somebody and share things with them. And what it turned out was that when once they were done with their time together in bed, she had to roll off onto this cot and sleep by herself because this guy couldn't handle having anybody else in his bed with him. And I just thought that was the saddest
在闲逛，我们去了她家拿东西。我进去了，他们有一个开放式的卧室计划。我看了看，有一张巨大的床，像一张特大号床，但在床旁边有一张小小的婴儿床。我记得我说过，哦，那是什么？她变得非常严肃。他说，就像，看，当你进入一段关系时，你必须确保你能够与某人亲密并与他们分享事情。结果是，当他们在一起在床上度过时光后，她不得不滚到这张婴儿床上独自睡觉，因为这家伙无法忍受床上还有别人。我只是觉得那是
thing I've ever seen in my life. And so I remember when we were scouting that location and there was that little stool at the end or that bench at the end of the bed. I can't remember if it was in the script or if we took it and ran with it. But I've ever seen the Lee and Jean like we had, I told them that story. I said, like, how funny we have to have this thing where Michael can't sleep in the bed. And so that's what we did. And I remember when we were shooting it, it was made me laugh so much because, you know, the way that Steve Carell would curl up on that bench. And my whole thing was like, okay, we got to hang on this as long as we can. And so, you know, we have Jan going like,
我这辈子见过的最悲伤的事情。所以我记得当我们考察那个地点时，床尾有那个小凳子或长凳。我不记得它是在剧本里，还是我们拿了它并继续发挥。但我见过李和吉恩，就像我们有，我告诉了他们那个故事。我说，我们必须有这个迈克尔不能睡在床上的东西，这多有趣。所以这就是我们所做的。我记得当我们拍摄它时，它让我笑得太厉害了，因为，你知道，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔蜷缩在那张长凳上的方式。我的整件事是，好吧，我们必须尽可能长时间地坚持这一点。所以，你知道，我们有简说，
Oh, he fits perfectly. Ha, ha, ha. And the I just tried to get every last frame out of every just staring at Michael on this bench. And it's silent. And it's just completely uncomfortable. And it makes me laugh still to this day. Now lady, that clip suggests that maybe this was the condo guys bed and bench. Because he said when they scouted the location, they saw the bench or maybe just a bench and then we recreated it. But I have a bench at the end of my bed, no one sleeps on it. But this is a very popular thing. I have an upholstered bench at the foot of my bed as well. It's where I like sort of lay my robe at night, you know, I like kick
哦，他非常合适。哈哈哈哈。然后我只是试图从每一个盯着迈克尔在长凳上的镜头中榨出最后一帧。它是沉默的。它完全不舒服。直到今天它仍然让我发笑。现在女士，那个片段暗示也许这是公寓家伙的床和长凳。因为他说当他们考察地点时，他们看到了长凳，或者也许只是长凳，然后我们重新创造了它。但我床尾有一张长凳，没有人睡在上面。但这是一件非常流行的事情。我的床脚也有一张软垫长凳。这是我晚上放长袍的地方，你知道，我喜欢踢
off my slippers, I put my robe on the bench. Yeah. And it's all there for me in the morning. My bench could not fit a grown man. It's a tiny little bench. I actually really looked at that bench and I was like, Oh, they found a wide bench. That's a substantial bench. Yes, exactly. It's just big enough that you believe it, but still small enough that it's just so sad. Yeah. And also, just again, Michael has no space in his own home. She has both guest rooms she's using. And now he doesn't even get to sleep in his bed. It's so sad. It's tragic. And now I've got a fun fact. This scene of the bedroom tour specifically. This scene
脱下拖鞋，我把长袍放在长凳上。是的。第二天早上它就在那儿等着我。我的长凳可坐不下一个成年男子。那是一张很小的长凳。我当时真的看了看那张长凳，心想，哦，他们找了一张宽长凳。那是一张很结实的长凳。是的，没错。它刚好大到让你相信它，但又小到让人觉得非常可悲。是的。而且，再说一次，迈克尔在自己家里根本没有空间。她把两间客房都占用了。现在他连自己的床都睡不了了。太可悲了。这简直是悲剧。现在我有一个有趣的事实。这一幕，特别是卧室参观这一幕，
is John McCain's favorite scene from the office. And I can tell you why. Yeah. How do you know that? That's such a random tidbit to know. BJ Novak was at a dinner party with John McCain. I would love to hear that story, how that came about. That's fascinating to me. That's very unbranded, though, for BJ. BJ finds himself in these eclectic groups of people all the time. So this was what? A few years ago, he's at a dinner party. John McCain's there. Yeah, you want to be BJ's plus one to a dinner party because he's going to take you to a cool group. Yeah. He was at this dinner party and someone walked up to him and said, John McCain is a huge fan of the office. Would
是约翰·麦凯恩在《办公室》中最喜欢的一幕。我可以告诉你原因。是吗？你怎么知道的？这可是个很随机的趣闻。BJ·诺瓦克曾和约翰·麦凯恩一起参加过晚宴。我很想听听那个故事，它是怎么发生的。这对我来说太迷人了。不过，这对BJ来说很不符合他的个人品牌。BJ总是发现自己身处各种各样的社交圈中。所以这是什么时候的事？几年前，他在参加一个晚宴。约翰·麦凯恩也在场。是的，你肯定想成为BJ参加晚宴时的“加一”名额，因为他会带你进入一个很酷的圈子。是的。他在那个晚宴上，有人走到他面前说，约翰·麦凯恩是《办公室》的超级粉丝。你
you like me to make an introduction? Now, I've experienced this too with politicians. A lot of times politicians, they have a person whose job it is to whisper things in their ears that are really specific about the other guests at a party because they vetted everyone at the party so that when the politician meets you, they can say something really specific and personal. It's like the scene you guys in Devil Wears Prada, right? Anne Hathaway's next to Meryl Streep. They're at that big shindig in Paris and she's telling her every little person that walks up some little tidbit. Yes. So BJ was like, oh, he's probably been told I work on this show called The Office in Yadda Yadda. So BJ was like, I'm going
想让我为你引荐一下吗？现在，我也曾有过这种与政客打交道的经历。很多时候，政客们身边都有专门负责在他们耳边低语的人，告诉他们关于宴会上其他客人的具体信息，因为他们会提前调查宴会上的每一个人，这样当政客见到你时，他们就能说出一些非常具体和私人的话。就像你们在《穿普拉达的女王》里看到的那样，对吧？安妮·海瑟薇在梅丽尔·斯特里普旁边。他们在巴黎参加那个大型聚会，她告诉她每一个走过来的人的一些小趣闻。是的。所以BJ当时想，哦，他可能被告知我在这部叫《办公室》的剧里工作，诸如此类。所以BJ想，我要
to put him to the test and I'm going to ask him specifically, John McCain, tell me one of your favorite scenes from The Office. BJ. Right? Oh my gosh. Okay. So when he met him, he did it. He said, what's one of your favorite scenes? And John McCain said, I love that scene in the dinner party when they're given the house tour and they walk into the bedroom and the video cameras up in the background and the bench. And he just went on and on with such great detail that BJ knew, oh, this is for real. This guy does love The Office. That's so wild. It's so specific. Yeah. It's such a specific scene. It was. Well, he picked a good episode and he picked a good scene because when I was rewatching this with my
考验他一下，我要专门问他，约翰·麦凯恩，告诉我一个你在《办公室》中最喜欢的场景。BJ，对吧？天哪。好吧。所以当他见到他时，他真的这么做了。他说，你最喜欢的场景是什么？约翰·麦凯恩说，我喜欢晚宴那一集里他们参观房子，走进卧室，背景里有摄像机，还有那张长凳的场景。他滔滔不绝地说了那么多细节，BJ就知道，哦，这是真的。这家伙确实很喜欢《办公室》。太疯狂了。太具体了。是的。这确实是一个非常具体的场景。确实。好吧，他选了一集好剧，也选了一个好场景，因为当我和我
husband Lee, this was the scene where I thought we were going to have to pause because he couldn't catch his breath. He was like laughing so hard. All right. Well, speaking of having to like pause to catch your breath because you're laughing so hard. Jenna, up next is the scene with the tiny TV. Oh my God. The tiny plasma TV that only comes out two inches from the wall. There are two times when I laughed so hard on our show that I thought I wasn't going to ever recover. This was one of them. There's streaming down our face. We had a fan question from Maddie as Paula T. Kennedy H. How many takes did you guys have to do when Michael was showing off his plasma TV? Guys,
丈夫李重温这一集时，这就是我以为我们不得不暂停的场景，因为他笑得喘不过气来。他笑得太厉害了。好吧，说到因为笑得太厉害而不得不暂停喘口气。珍娜，接下来是那个小电视的场景。天哪。那个离墙只有两英寸的超小等离子电视。我们在拍摄时有两次笑得太厉害，以至于我以为我永远也缓不过来了。这就是其中之一。我们眼泪都流出来了。我们收到了来自Maddie as Paula T. Kennedy H的粉丝提问。迈克尔展示他的等离子电视时，你们拍了多少次？伙计们，
John Krasinski talks about this. I'm going to turn it over to him. When we got to the moment with the television, I think there was an energy in the room that was overwhelming. I was already quaking with laughter. It wouldn't have taken much for me to laugh and then throw in maybe one of my favorite jokes in the entire show. I remember at the table read laughing, but then to see Steve again with that beaming face of pride just turn to us and say, you won't believe what I have. Also, look what it can do when company comes over. I can just do this. I'm pretty sure that the distance between the TV and the wall was like an inch and a half. He was so proud that it comes out to watch
约翰·卡拉辛斯基谈到了这一点。我要把它交给他。当我们拍到电视那一刻时，我觉得房间里的那种能量简直让人无法抗拒。我已经笑得浑身发抖了。我不需要太费力就能笑出来，然后再加上我整部剧中最喜欢的笑话之一。我记得在剧本朗读会上我就笑个不停，但再次看到史蒂夫那张充满自豪的脸转向我们说，你绝对想不到我有什么。还有，看看当有客人来时它能做什么。我可以就这样。我很确定电视和墙之间的距离大概只有一英寸半。他非常自豪，它能伸出来，让你在
TV in the comfort of your own home. Then you push it back a good inch and a half to hide it away when company comes. Luckily, the outtakes are out there in the world. You can see, I mean, Jenna can tell you, but I think that it took probably 19 or 20 takes before I was even able to stand up vertically in that scene without doubling over. Again, as I've always said, I'm a crier laughter. When I laugh that hard, my entire face turns red with tears and the pressure that's filling in my face for trying not to laugh and to no avail. I don't know why I even try not to laugh. I should just let it out and then my face wouldn't turn beat red in every scene. That is without a doubt. One of my favorite
自己家里舒适地看电视。然后当有客人来时，你把它推回去一英寸半把它藏起来。幸运的是，花絮已经在网上了。你可以看到，我的意思是，珍娜可以告诉你，但我认为大概拍了19或20次，我才能在那一幕中垂直站立而不弯下腰。再说一次，正如我一直说的，我是那种笑起来会哭的人。当我笑得那么厉害时，我的整张脸都会因为眼泪和为了忍住不笑而产生的压力而变红，但无济于事。我不知道我为什么要忍住不笑。我应该直接笑出来，这样我的脸就不会在每一幕里都变得通红了。那毫无疑问是我最喜欢的
scenes and I will cherish that memory for the rest of my career. You can hear him losing it, just retelling it, you know? Yes. Well, Jenna, one of my daughter's favorite things since we've been doing Office Ladies is watching the bloopers. My daughter, Isabelle, absolutely loves them. She watches them over and over. I think it's so fun for her to see you and I laughing and these people that she's known since she was born cracking up. So she actually helped me gather all the bloopers for this episode. She knew right where they were. She even knew time codes, Jenna. I love it. You're passing along the love of time codes to Isabelle. I am. So I feel like we have to hear the blooper
场景之一，我会在我职业生涯的余下时间里珍藏那段记忆。你可以听到他讲到这里时又笑得不行了，对吧？是的。好吧，珍娜，自从我们开始做《办公室女士》以来，我女儿最喜欢的事情之一就是看花絮。我女儿伊莎贝尔绝对喜欢它们。她一遍又一遍地看。我觉得看到你和我大笑，还有她从出生起就认识的这些人笑得前仰后合，对她来说太有趣了。所以她实际上帮我收集了这一集的所有花絮。她知道它们就在哪里。她甚至知道时间码，珍娜。我喜欢这个。你把对时间码的热爱传给了伊莎贝尔。我是。所以我感觉我们必须听听这一幕的
of this scene because it's so wonderful. Sam, can you play that? I guess what surround sound means is that, right over here, Tim. Two speakers. Damn. We have two speakers. What? Honey? Oh, Jesus. This is terrible. We'll never finish this episode. Check this out. Folds. Sorry. Oh, my God. Lady, it makes me laugh just hearing it. It makes me crack up. Lady, Steve did a whole runner where they just let him go with this TV. Oh, man. And he tries to explain that the TV has surround sound. And what he means by that is that the screen is surrounded by a speaker. The whole thing was you've gone to someone's house when they've just gotten their new TV system with their new sound speakers and they're so excited
花絮，因为它太精彩了。萨姆，你能播放一下吗？我想环绕声的意思是，就在这里，蒂姆。两个扬声器。该死。我们有两个扬声器。什么？亲爱的？哦，天哪。这太糟糕了。我们永远也拍不完这一集。看看这个。折叠。抱歉。哦，天哪。女士，光是听到这个就让我发笑。这让我笑得前仰后合。女士，史蒂夫做了一整段即兴表演，他们就让他对着这台电视发挥。哦，伙计。他试图解释电视有环绕声。他的意思是屏幕被一个扬声器环绕着。整件事就是你去了某人家里，他们刚买了带新音响系统的新电视，他们非常兴奋地
to show it off. Maybe they even like play part of a movie for you, right? Yes. That was the inspiration for this. And so Steve was going to bring that energy of like we were sitting in a professionally done home theater, right? Yes. But instead, he's just talking about this tiny TV, which, by the way, is not even a plasma TV. It's just a flat screen TV, but he keeps referring to it as a plasma TV. Oh, my God. Jenna, do you know what I love is that how this is still a joke with the cast. So a few years ago, you guys, we've talked about this before. We have a cast text thread where we will text and check in, say hello, little clips, pictures of our kids. Creed usually sings us a song at Christmas
展示它。也许他们甚至会为你播放电影的一部分，对吧？是的。这就是灵感来源。所以史蒂夫想带来那种感觉，就像我们坐在专业打造的家庭影院里一样，对吧？是的。但相反，他只是在谈论这台小电视，顺便说一句，它甚至不是等离子电视。它只是一台平板电视，但他一直把它称为等离子电视。哦，天哪。珍娜，你知道我喜欢什么吗？那就是这个笑话在演员中依然有效。所以几年前，伙计们，我们之前谈过这个。我们有一个演员群聊，我们会发信息问候，说你好，发一些小片段，孩子们的照片。克里德通常会在圣诞节给我们唱首歌，
and he'll text us, you know, him at home with his like elf hat on. And Jenna sent a photo to all of us. You were on a job and you walked in to like a little dressing room they had for you. And there was the tiniest TV mounted on the wall. Jenna, and you sent us a picture and we all started cracking up. Yes. I walked into this dressing room and I thought to myself, you could hold this in your hand. Why have they mounted it on the wall? It was so reminiscent of the dinner party episode. I was so excited to send that text and people were loving it. It will never get old to me that scene. I can watch it and watch it and watch it. But there are so many things in this living room that made me laugh on a second watch, Jenna.
他会发信息给我们，你知道，他戴着精灵帽在家里。珍娜给我们所有人发了一张照片。你当时在工作，走进他们为你准备的小更衣室。墙上挂着一台最小的电视。珍娜，你发了照片给我们，我们都笑得不行。是的。我走进那个更衣室，心想，你一只手就能拿住它。为什么要把它挂在墙上？这太让人想起晚宴那一集了。我非常兴奋地发了那条信息，大家都很喜欢。那个场景对我来说永远不会过时。我可以一遍又一遍地看。但在第二遍观看时，客厅里有很多东西让我发笑，珍娜。
And I also remembered it the day we were filming because I was seated by it, that janky side table that Michael made. It is the saddest looking table and he's so proud of it. It looks like scrap wood. Like if you got a crate of firewood that he used the crate to make the table and the dialogue cracked me up too. Jim is like, is that chestnut? And he's like, I think it's either pine or Nordic cherry. It's like, what? Angela, it's time for you to arrive at this dinner party. Oh, Andy and Angela, here we come. We had a fan question from Hailey M. Angela, are you starting to break when Michael goes in for the hug, which you refuse? Yes. Yes. I pretty much, like John said, the minute
而且拍摄那天我也记得，因为我坐在它旁边，迈克尔做的那个蹩脚的边桌。它看起来是最可悲的桌子，而他却为它感到自豪。它看起来像废木头。就像如果你有一箱柴火，他用那个箱子做了这张桌子。对话也让我笑得不行。吉姆问，那是栗木吗？他说，我想是松木或北欧樱桃木。这简直是，什么？安吉拉，该你参加这个晚宴了。哦，安迪和安吉拉，我们来了。我们收到了来自Hailey M的粉丝提问。安吉拉，当迈克尔过来拥抱你，而你拒绝时，你是不是开始笑场了？是的。是的。我几乎，就像约翰说的，那一分钟
I walked in that room and saw everything, just the minute we started those scenes, I was already tickled and everything from then on was just me trying not to laugh. I have a fun catch at six minutes 34 seconds. When Andy takes off his coat, underneath his coat, he is wearing a turtleneck with a shirt over it and then a sweater tied around his neck. Oh yeah, he's in prime preppy mode. This was a bit that Jean, our writer, came up with. He just thought it would be really, really funny to have a person who has tied a sweater around their neck take their coat off. Yeah, they had that ready to go underneath. Well, you know, I said I would let you guys know when we had some belly hiding. It's
我走进那个房间看到一切，就在我们开始那些场景的那一分钟，我就已经被逗乐了，从那以后的一切都只是我在努力不笑。我在6分34秒有一个有趣的发现。当安迪脱下外套时，外套里面他穿着一件高领毛衣，外面套着衬衫，脖子上还系着一件毛衣。哦，是的，他处于典型的预科生模式。这是我们的编剧吉恩想出的一个点子。他只是觉得让一个脖子上系着毛衣的人脱掉外套会非常非常有趣。是的，他们在那下面准备好了。好吧，你知道，我说过当我们要藏肚子时会告诉你们。它
happening all through the episode, but one of my favorites is this giant bouquet of flowers. That was to hide my belly. Yes. That's how big my belly is. Look at that bouquet of flowers. They had to make the bouquet that big because the point of it was for Andy to give his hostess some flowers, but the reason they're so large was because they were a belly hide. There's a great blooper from this as well. If you guys go back and re-watch them, but I have a little catch I want to point out. What is it? At six minutes, 44 seconds, I'm standing next to Jan. While Andy's doing the tuna, tuna, bet you get a lot of tuna, eat a lot of tuna that whole bit. Yep. I just, as an actor, just my own little prep that I decided
在整集中都在发生，但我最喜欢的是这束巨大的花。那是为了藏我的肚子。是的。我的肚子有那么大。看看那束花。他们不得不把花束做得那么大，因为它的目的是让安迪给他的女主人送花，但它们之所以那么大是因为它们是用来藏肚子的。这里也有一个很棒的花絮。如果你们回去重看，但我有一个小发现想指出。是什么？在6分44秒，我站在简旁边。当安迪在做金枪鱼，金枪鱼，打赌你吃了很多金枪鱼，吃了很多金枪鱼那整段时。是的。我只是，作为一名演员，我自己决定做的准备工作就是我一直盯着简的胸部。我的意思是，我视线正好对着它们。她穿着高跟鞋。她比我高。它们就在那里。我决定给她一个评判性的眼神，安吉拉·马丁式的傲慢表情。保罗·费格走到我面前说，天哪，安吉拉，我刚才在镜头里捕捉到你在用评判的眼神看简的胸部。他说，你每次都得这么做。我做了。它出现在剧里了。这只是那些没有剧本但最终出现在屏幕上的小瞬间之一。重温这些总是很有趣。但那是一个非常“当然安吉拉会那样做”的时刻。当然，对吧？我很高兴他们捕捉到了。这也是我们发现的时候，安吉拉，炖牛膝骨至少需要
to do was I just stared at Jan's boobs. I mean, I was eye level to them. She's in heels. She's taller than me. They're right there. I decided to throw her a little judgy shade, Angela Martin sass look. Paul Feig came up to me and was like, oh my gosh, Angela, I just caught in camera that you're giving Jan's boobs the judgy look. He was like, you got to do that every time. I did. It made it in the show. It's just one of those little moments that wasn't scripted that ends up on the screen. It's always fun to relive those. But that is a big, of course, Angela would do that moment. Of course, right? I'm so glad they caught it. This is also when we find out, Angela, that the Asabuco will not be
三个小时才能准备好。我喜欢帕姆说的那句台词，她说，你是说从现在起三个小时，还是从你开始做的四点钟算起三个小时？珍娜，当我重温这一幕时，那是你说的最像现实生活中你的台词之一。确实。感觉那一刻，珍娜是在以朋友的身份说这句话。我想，那会是珍娜。她会说，不，但你，你提前计划了。肯定。如果你知道它需要三个小时，肯定你已经预估了你上菜的时间。我觉得那是我在回应主人时可能会说的话。有时在西班牙，他们午夜才吃饭。所以入乡随俗，入乡随俗，我想我们现在
ready for at least three hours. I love Pam's line when she says, do you mean three hours from now or three hours from four o'clock when you started it? Jenna, when I rewatched the scene, that is one of the lines that you say that is most like you in real life. It is. It just felt like in that moment, Jenna was saying it as your friend. I was like, that would be Jenna. She'd be like, no, but you, you planned ahead. Surely. If you know it takes three hours, surely you had already estimated the time that you'd be serving it. I feel like that is something I could possibly say in response to a host. Sometimes in Spain, they eat at midnight. So when in Rome, when in Rome, I guess we're
要坐下来喝点酒了。迈克尔祝酒。他提到了葡萄酒的橡木余味。吉恩告诉我史蒂夫即兴发挥了那句台词。你在开玩笑吧。橡木余味。天哪，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。好吧，现在简需要放松一下。她想放点音乐。是的。我不知道你知不知道，但她以前的助理亨特是一位出色的音乐家。所以她要放他的CD。叫《被猎杀者》。是的。然后她要在我们所有人面前独自跳舞。我们收到了一些关于那个的粉丝来信。阿曼达·B，伊利亚娜·B和加布·G说，请告诉我们关于简的舞蹈的一切。好吧，我从这个开始。吉恩告诉我，在我们拍了几次
going to sit around and drink some wine now. Michael makes a toast. He notes the oaky afterbirth of the wine. Jean told me that Steve improvised that line. You're kidding. Oaky afterbirth. Oh my gosh, Steve Carell. Well, now Jan needs to relax. She wants to put some music on. Yeah. And I don't know if you know this, but her former assistant Hunter is a fabulous musician. And so she's going to put on his CD. It's called the hunted. Yeah. And then she's going to dance by herself in front of all of us. We got some fan mail about that. Amanda B, Iliana B and Gabe G said, please tell us everything about Jan's dance. Well, I'll start with this. Jean told me that after we did a few
马洛拉独自跳舞的镜头后，他有个主意，她应该试着把吉姆拉进舞蹈中。所以他把她拉到一边，私下给了她那个建议。约翰不知道会发生那种事。马洛拉只是顺势而为。我们也不知道。而且珍娜，当我重温那一幕时，现在知道了这一点，对吧？因为吉恩和你分享了，然后马洛拉和我谈了这件事。我观察了我们的表情，不仅是约翰的，我还观察了你和我的，因为这对我们三个人来说都是个惊喜。你可以清楚地看到我们俩脸上的表情，就像，哇，发生了什么？太完美了。好吧，就像安吉拉说的，我们确实问过马洛拉这件事。她告诉了我们
takes of Malora dancing on her own, he had the idea that she should try to pull Jim into the dance. So he got her aside and he gave her that note privately. John did not know that was going to happen. Malora just ran with it. And we didn't know either. And Jenna, when I rewatched that now knowing that, right, because Jean shared that with you and then Malora talked to me about it. I watched our faces, not only John's, but I watched yours in mine because it was a surprise to all three of us. And you can really see a look on both of our faces of like, whoa, what was happening? It was perfect. Well, like Angela said, we did ask Malora about this. And she told us
她跳舞背后的灵感。表演中最有趣的时刻之一就是和约翰·卡拉辛斯基一起跳亨特写的那首歌。感觉就像是对迈克尔的一种美妙的讽刺，如此被动攻击。而且我是一名舞者。所以我真的只想稍微有点，比如，跟不上节拍。我想确保我真的努力做到非常不合适，但也只是稍微有点跟不上节拍，有点醉，有点微醺。我觉得这对迈克尔来说会是一个更好的，你知道，更好的讽刺，因为简和迈克尔在这一集的那一刻就像在打仗一样。
the inspiration behind her dancing. One of the most fun moments to play was the dancing with John Krasinski for the song that Hunter had written. It just felt like such a wonderful sort of jab at Michael, so passive aggressive. And also I'm a dancer. So I really wanted to just be a little like off the beat. I wanted to make sure that I really tried hard to just be so inappropriate, but also just like a little bit off the beat, a little drunk, kind of a little tipsy. And I felt like that would be even a better, you know, even a better jab to Michael because Jan and Michael are like at war at that point in the episode.
我喜欢她有点跟不上节拍。哦，是的。简根本不在乎。你知道，如果你真的仔细想想，她会在这个尴尬的晚宴上站起来，在所有人面前播放她以前的情人写给她的歌，这真是太疯狂了。是的。安吉拉，我们收到了很多关于这首歌的邮件。汉娜·H，布里·P，布兰迪·R，迈尔斯·W和里根·C。他们想知道是谁写并演唱了亨特在CD上的歌，这是否证明了简和亨特有私情？是的。而且我们认为迈克尔在播放这首歌时知道吗？
I love that she's a little off the beat. Oh, yeah. Jan just doesn't give a s***. You know, it's so like crazy to think if you really think it through that she would get up at this awkward dinner party and play a song her former lover wrote about her and him in front of all of them. Yes. Angela, we got so much mail about this song. Hannah H, Bree P, Brandy R, Miles W, and Reagan C. They want to know who wrote and performed Hunter's song on the CD and is it evidence that Jan and Hunter had a love affair? Yes. And do we think that Michael knew when she played the song?
我告诉你们，吉恩和李写了歌词。它不是由扮演亨特的演员唱的。它实际上是由《新色情者》乐队的托德·范西录制并演唱的，他也写了音乐。但听着，吉恩告诉我，他和李写了一个长得多的版本，歌词非常俗气。他说他们写了太久，但他们写这首俗气的情歌时玩得很开心。他们有三周时间，所以他们一直在修补。好吧，我想托德也录制了那个加长版，吉恩发给了我一个链接。在加长版中，很明显这首歌是关于简的。很明显
I'll tell you guys, Jean and Lee wrote the words to the song. It was not sung by the actor who played Hunter. It was actually recorded and sung by Todd Fancy of the new pornographers who wrote the music as well. But get this, Jean told me that he and Lee wrote a much longer version of the song with really cheesy lyrics. He said they worked on it for way too long, but they were just having so much fun writing this cheesy love song. And they had three weeks, so they kept tinkering. Well, I guess Todd also recorded that extended version of the song and Jean sent me a link. And in the extended version, it is very clear that this song is about Jan. It is very clear
他们至少发生过一次性关系。所以我让萨姆截取了一个片段，这样我们就能听到这一段。安吉拉，他说公司规则，去他的。而且显然他的父母不喜欢这段关系，因为他也说他不在乎他父母对此有什么看法。太搞笑了。那个版本制作得也很精良，有所有其他乐器。我喜欢他们选的那个，因为它更简单。是的。你知道。然后我也喜欢，当然，安迪不得不走。那每次都让我受不了。那是埃德，伙计们。那只是埃德随口说的。随着场景继续，我的角色在传真机的事情上把你出卖了。简又对你不高兴了。我的意思是，我不得不说，
that they have had sex at least once. So I had Sam pull a clip so we can hear this verse. Angela, he says corporate rules, effem. And also apparently his parents did not like this relationship because he also says he doesn't care what his parents have to say about it either. It's hilarious. That version is also very produced with all the other instruments. I liked the one that they picked because it was more simple. Yes. You know. And then I also love, of course, Andy has to go. That gets me every time. And that's Ed, you guys. That was just Ed throwing that in there. As the scene continues, my character throws you under the bus about the faxes. Jan is again not happy with you. I mean, I have to say,
安吉拉·马丁真的很高兴能有人和她一起评判帕姆。我知道。和任何人一起评判。任何时候有人被评判，那才是你说话的时候。那是我们建立联系的时候。是的。好吧，帕姆要溜去洗手间。她有一个独白。她不在乎别人怎么说她。她只是想吃东西。而且她认为在晚宴上这并不过分。她在洗手间里说话吗？是的，疯狂的事情是，安吉拉。所以帕姆在洗手间里有这个独白。然后吉姆要在洗手间里有一个独白，他说主人在玩他们自己让客人不舒服的独立游戏，而且他们都赢了。太棒了。约翰和我都在
Angela Martin is really happy to have someone to judge Pam with. I know. To judge anyone with. Any time someone's being judged, that's the only time you speak. That's when I bond. Yes. Well, Pam is going to sneak away to the bathroom. And she has a talking head. She does not care what people say about her. She just wants to eat. And she doesn't think it's a lot to ask at a dinner party. Is she talking in the bathroom? Yeah, here's the crazy thing, Angela. So Pam has this talking head in the bathroom. And then Jim is going to have a talking head in the bathroom where he says the hosts are playing their own separate game of making their guests uncomfortable and they're both winning. It's great. John and I are in
一个真正非常小的客用洗手间里。这就是我要问的。你知道它看起来像什么吗，珍娜？它看起来像很多家里都有的那种走廊洗手间。就像半卫。你知道，它只是一个马桶和一个洗手池。就是这样。那是一个半卫。这对我来说很有趣，因为我觉得这本可以是我们只是在我们周围竖起一些假墙。但没有，我们在一个真正的洗手间里。里面太小了。保罗·费格实际上谈到了这一点。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？我永远不会忘记和珍娜以及约翰挤在那个小洗手间里，拍摄那些关于他们感到不舒服的独白。我们真的，我当时站在洗手池上。
a real, very tiny guest bathroom. That's what I was going to ask. You know what it looks like, Jenna? It looks like that hall bathroom that a lot of homes have. It's like the half bath. You know, it's just like a toilet and a sink. And that's it. It was a half bath. And it's funny to me because I feel like this could have been something where you just put up like little fake walls around us. But no, we were in a real bathroom. It was so tiny in there. Paul Feig actually talks about this. Sam, will you play the clip? I'll never forget being jammed into that tiny bathroom with Jenna and with John shooting those talking heads about them being uncomfortable. And we were all literally, I was up on a sink.
兰德尔·艾因霍恩在里面拿着摄像机。他们听到了马特·马佐恩的声音，我们只是挤在这个小东西里拍摄这些独白。我从来没笑得这么厉害。我的意思是，天哪。好吧，在这两个小洗手间独白之间，有一个被删减的场景。是在吉姆和帕姆之间。他们躲在洗手间门外的走廊里。珍娜，帕姆正在吃她藏在钱包里或什么地方的燕麦棒。然后简抓住了你们。她说，你们在吃什么？太搞笑了。珍娜，你们当时笑得前仰后合。我们根本拍不下去。顺便说一句，我吃了太多燕麦棒，因为保罗·费格说，珍娜，我们必须相信
It was a Randall Einhorn was in there with a camera. They hear Matt Matzone and we were just jammed in this tiny thing shooting these talking heads. I never laughed so hard. I mean, my God. Well, between these two talking heads in the tiny bathroom, there is a scene that got deleted. It's between Jim and Pam. They are tucked in the hallway outside the bathroom door. And Jenna, Pam is eating a granola bar that she has like stashed away in her purse or something. And then Jan busts you guys. She's like, what are you guys eating? It's so funny. And Jenna, you guys were cracking up. We could not get through it. And by the way, I ate so much granola bar because Paul Feig was like, Jenna, we have to believe that
这是你等了几个小时才吃到的饭。你太饿了。所以我吃得全是燕麦棒。我们一直因为被马洛拉那双强烈的眼睛盯着而笑场。这让我受不了。我做不到。你们每次都显得真的很吃惊和害怕。然后这简直太搞笑了。好吧，在客厅里，我们正在进行一场痛苦地现实的猜谜游戏。如果你知道那个游戏的话，真的是一场名人游戏。轮到我，轮到我，轮到我了。如果你玩任何需要大声给出线索的猜谜或棋盘游戏，你会从一对夫妇身上学到很多，你真的会了解一对夫妇。珍娜，当我重温这一幕时，我想到了我和另一对夫妇玩过的猜谜游戏
this is like the meal you've been waiting hours for. You're so hungry. So I was so full of granola bar. And we kept breaking being confronted by Malora with her intense eyes. It did me in. I couldn't do it. You were both like genuinely startled and scared each time. And then it just is hilarious. Well, in the living room, we've got this painfully realistic game of charades going on. A game of celebrity really, if you know that game. My, my, my turn. My, my, my turn. You will learn so much about a couple. If you play any kind of charade or board game where you have to like give clues out loud, you really learn a couple. Jenna, when I rewatched this, I thought about a game of taboo I played with another couple
几年前。那个男人转向他的妻子说，哦，哦，我一直这样叫你。她说，哦，笨蛋。不，安吉拉。是的。房间里一片寂静。然后当她猜到时，他说，是的。他们就像，呜呼。他们在庆祝。我们都像，什么，呃，什么，我们刚刚学到了什么？但这就是那一刻。这就是正在发生的事情。我们看到迈克尔和简试图玩游戏。这真是太尴尬了。被动攻击性评论的数量令人难以置信。然后吉姆完全在戏弄迈克尔。哦，我知道。他知道迈克尔试图给出线索汤姆·克鲁斯，但他拒绝说出来。这太，太，太棒了。当然，安吉拉·马丁不懂任何流行
years ago. And the guy turned to his wife and goes, Oh, oh, I call you this all the time. And she goes, Oh, stupid. No, Angela. Yes. And the room was silent. And then when she got it, he was like, yes. And they were like, woohoo. And they were celebrating. And we were all like, what, uh, what, what did we just learn? But this is that moment. This is what is happening. We see Michael and Jan trying to play a game. And it is just so cringy. The amount of passive aggressive comments is incredible. And then Jim is totally messing with Michael. Oh, I know. He knows that Michael is trying to give the clue Tom Cruise, but he refuses to say it. It's so, so, so good. And of course, Angela Martin knows no pop
文化。所以她帮不上忙。安迪在给出线索方面很糟糕。太糟糕了。现在我们要迎来一个非常有争议的时刻。是吉姆试图在派对上甩掉你的时候吗？是的。吉姆假装接到房东的电话，说他的公寓被淹了，我想。他试图让帕姆和他一起逃离派对。他说，我们得走了。我们很抱歉。但迈克尔说，好吧，你们不需要两个人都去检查公寓。吉姆说，好吧，太好了。那帕姆，我稍后在家里见你。是的。帕姆说，嗯，不好意思，你可以买新东西，但你买不到新派对。是的。我们收到了很多关于这一刻的邮件。李·艾森伯格实际上在
culture. So she's no help. And Andy is horrible at giving clues. Terrible. Now we have a moment coming up that was very controversial. Is it when Jim tried to ditch you at the party? Yeah. Jim fakes a phone call from his landlord, saying that his apartment is flooded, I guess. And he tries to get Pam to come with him to escape the party. He's like, we got to go. We're so sorry. But Michael is like, well, you guys don't both need to go check on the apartment. And Jim is like, okay, great. Well, I'll see you at home later than Pam. Yeah. And Pam is like, um, excuse me, you can buy new stuff, but you can't buy a new party. Yeah. We got a lot of mail about this moment. And Lee Eisenberg actually spoke about
一次采访中谈到了这一点，在这一集播出时，因为我想在这一集在东海岸播出后，留言板上炸开了锅，全是网上的粉丝评论。人们真的，真的很生气吉姆会考虑把帕姆留在这个派对上。但吉恩和李说他们认为这是一个非常甜蜜、俏皮的场景。这有点像吉姆和帕姆之间的心理象棋比赛，而且帕姆最终赢了。他们认为帕姆是这一幕的胜利者，但人们无法逾越吉姆曾一度愿意把她留在那里的事实。好吧，那应该告诉你那个晚上有多糟糕。它并没有真正让我感到困扰，因为
this in an interview with office tally back when the episode aired, because I guess after this aired on the East Coast, the message boards blew up with fan comments online. People were really, really mad that Jim would consider leaving Pam behind at this party. But Jean and Lee said they thought it was a really sweet, playful scene. And it sort of was like, a mental chess match between Jim and Pam, and that Pam ends up winning. And they thought Pam was the victor of this scene, but people could not get past the fact that for a moment Jim was willing to leave her there. Well, that should tell you how bad the night was going. It didn't really bump me because
他一开始把你包括在内了。只有当他受到挑战时，他才说，好吧，那我就走了。好吧，晚上现在已经陷入了沉默。每个人都坐在那里什么也不说。他们已经沉默地坐了多久了？我不知道。我的意思是，简完全躺着，头向后仰，闭着眼睛。好吧，帕姆觉得有点冷。所以迈克尔把他的夹克给她。这激怒了简。这一幕太精彩了。马洛拉和史蒂夫太棒了。但她的眼神，马洛拉给你的眼神，然后慢慢瞥向迈克尔，然后又瞥向帕姆。然后你看到她在思考和计划说一些关于他的尴尬的事情。
he included you in the beginning. It's only when he was challenged that he was like, okay, well, I'm gone. Well, the evening has now dissolved into just silence. It's just everyone sitting around saying nothing. And how long have they been sitting there just in silence? I don't know. I mean, Jan is fully reclined with her head back and her eyes closed. Well, Pam gets a little chilly. So Michael offers her his jacket. And this sets off Jan. This scene is so brilliant. Malora and Steve are so amazing. But her look, the look Malora gives you and then slowly glances back over to Michael and then glances back to Pam. And then you see her thinking and planning to say something embarrassing about him.
简讲的故事是她很抱歉这么冷，但他们不得不更换滑动门。你可以看到门上有一块巨大的蓝色防水布。原因是因为迈克尔听到冰淇淋车的声音时冲过了玻璃。是的。简说，这是一个可爱的故事。迈克尔冲过了滑动玻璃门，因为他以为他听到了冰淇淋车的声音。迈克尔说，停下。我不喜欢这个故事。好吧，行。看，我喜欢冰淇淋。所以起诉我吧。然后他说，等等，我不应该那样说，因为她会起诉你，因为她喜欢诉讼。然后他说玻璃非常干净。我说，它是隐形的。她直接爆发了。她说，
The story Jan tells is that she's very sorry it's so chilly, but they're having to have their sliding door replaced. And you can see a big blue tarp over the door. And the reason is because Michael ran through the glass when he heard the ice cream truck. Yeah. Jan's like, it's a cute story. Michael ran through the sliding glass doors because he thought he heard the ice cream truck. And Michael's like, stop it. I don't like the story. Okay, fine. Look, I like ice cream. So sue me. And then he's like, wait, I shouldn't say that because she will sue you because she loves lawsuits. And then he said the glass was extremely clean. And I was like, it was invisible. And she just erupts. She's like,
我是对的。你是对的。因为在我住在这里之前，玻璃上总是布满污迹。然后我搬进来，我把它擦干净了。所以我想这让我成了魔鬼。然后他们俩就像疯狂地大笑，眼神疯狂。他说，哈哈，是的，她是魔鬼。这简直是，哦，天哪，这是两个精神失常的人。这就是吉恩告诉我的关于这一幕的事情，安吉拉。他告诉我这一集的基调是“地狱般的晚宴”。想法是迈克尔在地狱里，简是魔鬼。哦，所以他们围绕这个主题做了很多事情。例如，他们设计了马洛拉的服装，让她穿红色。对于这一幕，他们写了
I'm so right. You're so right. Because before I lived here, the glass was always covered in smudges. And then I moved in and I cleaned it. So I guess that makes me the devil. And then they're both like crazy laughing with like crazy eyes. And he's like, haha, yeah, she is the devil. And it is, oh my God, it's two people unhinged. Here's what Jean told me about this scene, Angela. He told me that the theme of this episode was quote, dinner party from hell. And the idea was that Michael is in hell and Jan is the devil. Oh, and so they did a lot of things toward this theme. For example, they designed Malora's wardrobe so that she was dressed in red. And for this scene where they wrote
那句台词，我想我是魔鬼。然后，你知道，迈克尔回应说我在地狱里。他们特意把她放在熊熊燃烧的火炉前。然后在房间里，他们点燃了她所有的蜡烛，围绕着迈克尔，这样他看起来确实身处地狱的火焰中。但马洛拉即兴发挥了那一刻，她在头上做了小魔鬼角，这太，太搞笑了。但是的，如果你环顾这个公寓，有很多红色的东西。确实。而且你知道，我在11分5秒捕捉到了那个红色的锅状东西，那是她被解雇时拿走的，它从盒子里掉了出来，他们不得不把它放回盒子里。它放在小桌子上她旁边。惊人的细节。
that line, I guess I'm the devil. And then, you know, Michael responds and I'm in hell. They purposely placed her in front of a roaring fire. And then in the room, they have all of her candles lit all around Michael so that he does appear to be in the flames of hell. But Malora improvised that moment where she made little devil horns on her head, which is so, so funny. But yeah, if you look around this apartment, there's a ton of red stuff. There is. And you know, I caught at 11 minutes, five seconds, that red pot-like thing that she took when she was fired in the job and it dropped out of the box and they had to put it back in the box. It's seated next to her on the little table. Amazing detail.
我们马上要进入厨房享受女孩时光。在厨房里，她所有的炊具都是红色的。所有这些都是故意的。好吧，让我们谈谈这个厨房场景。帕姆想打破房间里的紧张气氛。她说，还有酒吗？简说，不，不，不，我去拿。不，实际上，让我们享受一些女孩时光。安吉拉，来吧。她把她们带进了厨房。好吧，珍娜，我们三个女孩在这个厨房里拍了几个场景。只有一个进入了这一集，但还有另一个，而且很棒。萨姆，你能播放吗？所以这个我基本上一起长大的女孩成了西弗吉尼亚小姐。然后突然，
We're about to go into the kitchen for some girls' time. And in the kitchen, all of her cookware is red. All of that was on purpose. Well, let's talk about this kitchen scene. Pam has wanted to break up the tension in the room. She's like, is there more wine? And Jen's like, no, no, no, I'll get it. No, actually, let's have some girl time. Angela, come on. And she takes them into the kitchen. Well, Jenna, there were a few scenes that we filmed us three gals in this kitchen. Only one made it into the episode, but there is another one and it's great. Sam, can you play it? So this girl that I basically grew up with becomes Miss West Virginia. And then suddenly,
所有的男孩都开始关注我。这很有趣，因为我甚至从未认为自己漂亮，直到人们开始向我指出。我是，简，哇，你比西弗吉尼亚小姐漂亮多了。哦，所以这就是为什么我，等等，帕姆，你的，你的问题是什么？你在哪里长大的？太不可思议了。不是很好吗？是的。她只是滔滔不绝地谈论西弗吉尼亚小姐，而我们只是坐在那里沉默，当她切东西时。她显然讨厌这个女人。我的问题是，你在哪里长大的？是的。在厨房场景中，你会注意到我站在柜台边的一个小壁架后面。我记得保罗·费格和我非常兴奋
all the boys start paying attention to me. And it was funny because I never even considered myself beautiful until people started pointing it out to me. And I was, Jen, wow, you are so much more beautiful than Miss West Virginia. Oh, so that is why I, wait, Pam, what was your, what was your question? Where did you grow up? It's incredible. Isn't it so good? Yeah. She just goes off about Miss West Virginia and we're just sitting there in silence as she's chopping things. She clearly hates this woman. My question was, where did you grow up? Yeah. And in the kitchen scene, you'll notice I'm standing behind a little ledge by the counter. And I remember Paul Feig and I were so excited
厨房里有一个壁架。他们不必建造那个。我完美地缩在里面，这样我们就可以藏住我的肚子。好吧，当女士们在厨房里享受时光时，迈克尔带男士们参观了车库。他也利用这段时间试图让他们投资“简的宁静”，他加入了。你不需要对他说超过一句话。这是我女儿在整集中最喜欢的台词，当他说，考虑过了。我加入了。是的。迈克尔说，你想投资1万美元在这个蜡烛生意上吗？考虑一下。考虑过了。我加入了。好吧，当我们问埃德关于他拍摄晚宴的记忆时，他谈到了
that there was a ledge in the kitchen. They didn't have to build that. And I fit perfectly tucked into it so we could hide my belly. Well, while the ladies are having their time in the kitchen, Michael gives the guys a tour of the garage. He also uses this time to try to get them to invest in serenity by Jan and he's in. You don't need to say more than a sentence to him. This is my daughter's favorite line in the whole episode is when he goes, thought about it. I'm in. Yeah. Michael's like, do you want to invest $10,000 into this candle business? Think about it. Thought about it. I'm in. Well, when we asked Ed about his memories from shooting the dinner party, he talked
他第一次看到这个车库的时候。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？在我们拍摄的某个时候，我走出了片场。我不知道。我想我可能只是去拿点零食或什么的。我透过我们拍摄的公寓车库看。车库也是这一集的一个地点。他们为车库做了所有的布景装饰，我注意到了里面一个惊人的细节，那就是迈克尔·斯科特车库里的所有物品都是他从电视购物节目中买的东西，比如深夜电视购物。这只是剧中的一个背景笑话。比如，我记得看到过一个Bowflex和肉类脱水机，所有
about the first time he saw this garage. Sam, can you play that clip? At some point while we were shooting, I stepped off the set. I don't. I think I was probably just going to get a snack or something at craft service. And I watched through the garage of the condo where we were shooting. And the garage was also a location in the episode. They had done all the set decoration for the garage and I noticed this amazing detail in there, which is that all of the items in Michael Scott's garage were things that he had bought from infomercials, like late night infomercials. And this was just like a background joke in the show. Like, I remember seeing like a bow flex and like a meat dehydrator, like all
这些随机的东西。这让我笑得太厉害了，也提醒了我《办公室》团队是多么不可思议。从制作设计、布景装饰，每一个层面的每个人，所有那些为这部剧工作的人都非常有创造力，并以非常大和非常小的方式为这部剧的喜剧做出了贡献。这一切都产生了很大的不同。无论如何，这是我关于那一集最喜欢的细节之一。安吉拉，我查过了。所以目前一套Bowflex系统起价约为1500美元，但迈克尔既有Bowflex又有Soloflex。而Soloflex大约是2400美元。然后就像埃德说的，比如肉类脱水机，任何电视上看到的东西都被塞进了这个空间，而且真的
this random stuff. And it just made me laugh so hard and was such a reminder of how incredible the office team was. Everyone at every level from production design, set decoration, all those details, all of those people that worked on the show were so creative and contributing to the comedy of that show in very big and very small ways. And it all made such a difference. Anyway, that's one of my favorite details about that episode. Angela, I looked it up. So currently a bow flex system starts around $1,500, but Michael had both a bow flex and a solo flex. And a solo flex is like $2,400. And then like Ed said, like meat dehydrator, just any as seen on TV item was shoved into the space and really
很贵的东西。有两盒La Cousette，比如荷兰烤箱。那些太贵了。它们在威廉索诺玛。这有点提醒了当奥斯卡坐下来问他，你在买什么？你在把钱花在什么上？我不知道你有没有注意到，还有标着“迈克尔的东西”的盒子。所以显然简翻遍了，把他的很多东西装进了盒子里，它们就在车库里住着。太可悲了。哦，是的，你知道壁炉旁的那两把椅子是那两个手形座椅吗？没错。但那些不在客厅里了。女士，我想我们应该休息一下。我们还有很多要谈的。哦，天哪，
pricey stuff. There's two boxes of La Cousette, like Dutch ovens. Those are so expensive. They're like at William Sonoma. And it just kind of is that reminder of when Oscar sat down with him and said, what are you buying? What are you spending your money on? And I don't know if you noticed, but there's also just boxes labeled Michael's stuff. So clearly Jan went through and just boxed up a bunch of his stuff and it's out there living in the garage. So sad. Oh yeah, you know the two chairs by that fireplace were those two hand seats. That's right. But those aren't in the living room anymore. Lady, I think we should take a break. We still have so much more to talk about. Oh my gosh,
德怀特和保姆甚至还没出现。好吧，我们会在休息后谈到那个。叮咚。哦，还有两个客人。简很困惑。她的整个晚宴都在这儿了。迈克尔不是。他知道门口是谁。是德怀特和梅尔维娜，他小时候的保姆。哦，别担心，他们带了两个酒杯和一个食物冷却器。是的。既然他们是不速之客，他们已经准备好了。别担心。还有两把草坪椅。所以他们有地方坐。酒杯是你见过的最大的。是的，它们是。这引发了一场争论。简想让迈克尔把他们赶走，但迈克尔坚持立场。是的。迈克尔说，听着，你
Dwight and the babysitter haven't even showed up yet. Well, we will get to that right after this break. Ding dong. Oh, there's two more guests. Jan is confused. Her whole dinner party is here. Michael is not. He knows who's at the door. It's Dwight and Melvina, his older babysitter from when he was a child. Oh, and don't worry, they've brought two wineglasses and a cooler of food. Yeah. Since they're unexpected, they've got it covered. Don't worry. And two lawn chairs. So they have a place to sit. The wineglasses are the biggest ones you'll ever see. Yes, they are. This sets off an argument. Jan wants Michael to send them away, but Michael stands his ground. Yeah. Michael's like, listen, you
说他不能来，因为他没有“加一”或者我们没有足够的酒杯。好吧，他带了酒杯，他还带了另一个人。我知道，我喜欢那个。他带了一个人。一个人。所以我们开始吧。简说，好吧，随你的便。迈克尔说，随我的便。事情什么时候顺过我的意？是的，当他想看《树桩》而她想看《魔法坏女巫》时，他们看了什么？《魔法坏女巫》。当她说她还没准备好要孩子时。迈克尔做了什么？他做了输精管结扎术。然后她决定我想要孩子。他做了输精管结扎术复通。但后来她又改变了主意。他又做了一次输精管结扎术。剪，啪，剪，啪，剪，啪。你知道三次输精管结扎术的身体代价吗
said he couldn't come because he didn't have a plus one or we didn't have enough wineglasses. Well, he brought the wineglasses and he brought another human. I know, I love that. He's brought a person. A person. So here we go. And Jan is like, fine, have it your way. And Michael's like, have it my way. When do things ever go my way? Yeah, when he wanted to see Stump and she wanted to see Wicked, what did they see? Wicked. When she said she wasn't ready to have children. What did Michael do? He had a vasectomy. Then she decided I want kids. He had the vasectomy reversed. But then she changed her mind again. He had another vasectomy. Sip, snap, sip, snap, sip, snap. Do you know the physical toll that three vasectomies
他说他不能来，因为他没有带伴侣的名额，或者我们没有足够的酒杯。好吧，他带了酒杯，还带了另一个人。我知道，我喜欢这样。他带了一个人。一个人。所以我们开始吧。简说，好吧，随你的便。迈克尔说，随我的便？我的事什么时候随过我的愿？是啊，当他想看《Stump》而她想看《女巫前传》时，他们看了什么？《女巫前传》。当她说她还没准备好要孩子时，迈克尔做了什么？他做了输精管结扎手术。后来她决定想要孩子了，他又做了输精管结扎复通手术。但后来她又改变了主意，他又做了一次输精管结扎手术。咔嚓，复通，咔嚓，复通，咔嚓，复通。你知道三次输精管结扎手术对身体造成的伤害吗
takes on a person? All of this happens in front of all of us. There is so much to unpack about this scene, guys. So buckle in. I mean, when we saw the bench, we thought it can't get weirder than the bench. And then we played celebrity. And now we're standing in the hallway of the condo yelling about vasectomies. Where can it go? Let's start with Dwight State, his former babysitter, Melvina. Angela Jean told me that they thought it would be really fun to offer this role to our longtime casting director, Allison Jones. But she said no. She refused. Greg wanted the incredible Beth Grant to play the role. Well, yes, Greg had worked with Beth before and knew her very well. You guys might recognize her from the
一个人身上？这一切就发生在我们所有人面前。伙计们，这一幕有太多值得深挖的地方了。所以系好安全带吧。我的意思是，当我们看到那张长凳时，我们以为不会比长凳更奇怪了。然后我们玩了名人游戏。现在我们站在公寓的走廊里大喊输精管切除术。还能去哪儿呢？让我们从德怀特的约会对象，他以前的保姆梅尔维娜开始说起。安吉拉·吉恩告诉我，他们认为把这个角色提供给我们长期的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯会非常有趣。但她说不。她拒绝了。格雷格想让了不起的贝丝·格兰特来演这个角色。嗯，是的，格雷格以前和贝丝合作过，非常了解她。你们可能从
film No Country for Old Men. I mean, she has a huge filmography. But at this time, that film had just come out. We reached out to Beth. And she told us the story of exactly how she was cast on the show. I was thrilled when I got the call to do this part and to be Reigns babysitter and girlfriend. It's demented. And I love it. And I had worked with Steve Carell fairly recently in Little Miss Sunshine. So I was already completely in love with him and did love the show. And I had worked with Greg Daniels on King of the Hill. And we ran into each other during the writer's guilt strike. And I think he saw me in my strike mode. I guess he knew I was right to be able to be that demented woman.
电影《老无所依》中认出她。我的意思是，她的电影作品非常多。但在当时，那部电影才刚刚上映。我们联系了贝丝。她告诉了我们她是如何被选中出演这部剧的。当我接到电话要演这个角色，成为雷恩的保姆和女朋友时，我非常激动。这太疯狂了。我喜欢它。而且我最近在《阳光小美女》中和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合作过。所以我已经完全爱上了他，也确实喜欢这部剧。而且我和格雷格·丹尼尔斯在《乡巴佬希尔》中合作过。我们在编剧罢工期间碰到了对方。我想他在罢工期间看到了我。我想他知道我是扮演那个疯狂女人的合适人选。
Well then Beth shares with us what it was like to do the scene at the front door. She's holding a cooler the whole time. This is all happening. It's her first scene of the episode. Here's what she had to say. Going to the door to that dinner party was so thrilling for me. It was so hard not to laugh. I felt that since I knew Steve, he was out to get me. He wanted me to break. And here I was a guest star, nervous with all you regulars, you fabulous comedians, you brilliant comic minds. And here I am, the guest star with Reigns and opening the door is Steve Carell just going for it. And I had started this riff and improvising to
好吧，然后贝丝和我们分享了在前门拍那场戏是什么感觉。她一直拿着一个冷藏箱。这一切都在发生。这是她这一集的第一场戏。这是她要说的话。走到那个晚宴的门口对我来说太刺激了。忍住不笑太难了。我觉得既然我认识史蒂夫，他就是想捉弄我。他想让我笑场。而我只是一个客串明星，和你们这些常驻演员、这些了不起的喜剧演员、这些才华横溢的喜剧天才在一起感到紧张。而我就是那个和雷恩一起的客串明星，开门的是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，他完全进入了状态。我开始即兴发挥，
the point that I was determined not to laugh. So I started almost grunting and crying. I don't know if you can hear it in the episode, but and tears in my eyes. And he said, Oh great. Now she's crying or something. And I leaned over. I was holding that cooler, you know, bringing our own food since we weren't invited holding that cooler. And I leaned over just shaking all over and came back up. And somehow I think I managed not to break. But that was the only time I managed not to break because you guys were just so hilarious. Jenna, we should share with everyone what line Steve improvised that sent us all to the floor. Yes. Please Steve improvise the line snip, snap, snip, snap. You have no idea the physical
以至于我下定决心不能笑。所以我开始几乎是哼哼和哭泣。我不知道你们在这一集中能不能听到，但是我的眼里含着泪水。他说，哦太棒了。现在她哭了或者什么的。我弯下腰。我拿着那个冷藏箱，你知道，因为没被邀请所以自带食物，拿着那个冷藏箱。我弯下腰，浑身发抖，然后又站了起来。不知何故，我想我成功地没有笑场。但那是我唯一一次成功没有笑场，因为你们实在是太搞笑了。珍娜，我们应该和大家分享一下史蒂夫即兴发挥的那句台词，让我们所有人都笑趴下了。是的。请史蒂夫即兴发挥了那句“剪掉，缝上，剪掉，缝上”。你根本不知道三次输精管切除术对一个人造成的身体
toll three vasectomies has on a person. I mean, you try not laughing with Steve Carell in front of you improvising stuff like that. We were all a goner. Well, it's interesting because Paul Feig sent in an audio clip about this and I'll let him explain it. But there's a reason why Steve improvised that line. Here you go. There's so many great things to think about and remember from this episode. But the one that makes me just realize how genius Steve Carell is in case anybody didn't realize that already is when the whole snip, snap run was it was a pretty dramatic scene of them like talking about having kids and all this. And so we did several takes of it. It was really good, but it was very dramatic. And I remember kind of saying
伤害有多大。我的意思是，你试着在史蒂夫·卡瑞尔面前不笑，他即兴发挥这种东西。我们都完了。嗯，这很有趣，因为保罗·费格发来了一段关于这个的音频片段，我会让他来解释。但史蒂夫即兴发挥那句台词是有原因的。给你。这一集有很多伟大的事情值得思考和记住。但让我意识到史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是多么天才的一件事，以防有人还没意识到，就是当整个“剪掉，缝上”的桥段出现时，那是一场相当戏剧性的戏，他们谈论生孩子之类的。所以我们拍了好几遍。真的很好，但非常戏剧化。我记得我当时对
to Steve, maybe let's do a take or just kind of find a little more humor in it. I know it's kind of hard because it's kind of a serious subject. And he's like, Oh, okay, yeah, I get it. And that's when he did it went off on the the whole snip, snap, snip, snap, which is just brilliant. I mean, that scene is so funny because it's so heartbreaking and gringy, but also hilarious. I remember that, Angela. I remember doing takes and takes of that scene where they were just going back and forth. And you could just see the pain and Michael that he wasn't a father and that Jan had been so manipulative of him. And it was, it was like a drama. And then Paul came over and talked to Steve. And they were like, how can we make this a comedy again? How can we keep the
史蒂夫说，也许我们拍一遍，或者试着在里面找点幽默感。我知道这有点难，因为这是一个严肃的话题。他说，哦，好的，是的，我明白了。那就是他开始即兴发挥整个“剪掉，缝上，剪掉，缝上”的时候，这简直太天才了。我的意思是，那一幕太搞笑了，因为它既令人心碎又尴尬，但也非常滑稽。我记得那个，安吉拉。我记得拍了又拍那场戏，他们只是来回争论。你可以看到迈克尔的痛苦，他没有孩子，简对他如此操纵。这就像一部戏剧。然后保罗走过来和史蒂夫谈话。他们就像，我们怎么能让它再次成为喜剧呢？我们怎么能保持
dark elements of this scene, but not let it get too heavy? Brilliant, Steve Carell. Yeah, he's so saves the moment. And it's hilarious. I mean, you're cringing. It's horrible. It's, but he makes it funny. Yeah. Well, now guys, we're going to sit down at the table. I guess dinner is ready. Near ready. Finally. Can I point something out? Yeah. If you look at the table, we all have wine glasses, right? Mm hmm. We also all have water glasses, which are wine glasses. So clearly Jan had more than six wine glasses because she is using them for water as well. She just didn't want Dwight to come, you guys, to her fancy party. He did not make the list. Well, Dwight has started eating. I mean, they brought their own food. They're wasting no time.
这一幕的黑暗元素，但又不让它变得太沉重？天才，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。是的，他真是拯救了那一刻。而且太搞笑了。我的意思是，你感到尴尬。这太可怕了。但是，他让它变得有趣。是的。好吧，现在伙计们，我们要坐在桌子旁了。我想晚餐准备好了。快准备好了。终于。我可以指出一件事吗？是的。如果你看桌子，我们都有酒杯，对吧？嗯嗯。我们还有水杯，也就是酒杯。所以很明显简有超过六个酒杯，因为她也用它们来喝水。你们这些家伙，她只是不想让德怀特来参加她那场高级派对。他没在名单上。好吧，德怀特已经开始吃了。我的意思是，他们自带了食物。他们一点时间也没浪费。
They're the only ones eating. Jan is still upset over what happened at the door. She's so upset, she has to excuse herself. She goes to the kitchen. Yeah. I mean, the last thing she said before she sat at that dining table was, I hate my life. Yeah. She's not in a good place. Jenna, there's a deleted scene that is so fantastic where you kind of whisper to Michael, go to Jan, go comfort her. You kind of do this little motion like, go say something. So he gets up and he walks over to her. Again, he's comforting her, but we're all witness to it. And it's so clumsy and awkward. And Sam, can you play the first part of that? Hey, no, no, no. Don't be sad. Don't be sad. I care about you and I support you.
他们是唯一在吃东西的人。简对门口发生的事情仍然感到不安。她太不安了，不得不找借口离开。她去了厨房。是的。我的意思是，她在坐在餐桌前说的最后一句话是，“我讨厌我的生活”。是的。她的状态不太好。珍娜，有一个被删减的场景非常精彩，你低声对迈克尔说，去找简，去安慰她。你做了这个小动作，就像，去说点什么。所以他站起来走到她身边。同样，他在安慰她，但我们都目睹了这一切。这太笨拙和尴尬了。萨姆，你能播放那段的第一部分吗？嘿，不，不，不。别难过。别难过。我在乎你，我支持你。
And you are smart and beautiful. And you have beautiful bosoms and you can't even tell they're fake unless you're naked. And I believe that with my support and your constant calls to Dr. Perry on my phone plan, with a little bit of a strain because I only have 20 anytime minutes a month. Every minute after that is 75 cents. You should look at some other plans. Oh, okay. Thanks, weirdo. But you know what? I'm month to month because I don't want to do your commitment. I remember when he turned to Beth and goes, oh, thanks, weirdo. We all lost it.
而且你聪明又漂亮。你有漂亮的胸部，除非你裸体，否则你甚至看不出它们是假的。我相信在我的支持下，加上你不断用我的手机套餐给佩里医生打电话，虽然有点吃力，因为我每个月只有20分钟的随时通话时间。之后每分钟75美分。你应该看看其他套餐。哦，好的。谢谢，怪胎。但你知道吗？我是按月付费的，因为我不想做出承诺。我记得当他转向贝丝说，哦，谢谢，怪胎。我们所有人都笑疯了。
Yeah. Jean said that's one of his favorite lines that got cut. Oh, really? Mm-hmm. He loves that moment. Michael continues to try to comfort Jan and it doesn't get any better, but it really paints a picture of how he feels about his home life with her. What were you saying to Jan? Honey, nobody in the complex likes you, but you have made this place all great. It's like a museum. You can't touch anything, which is a really strange way to feel at the place that you live. You have made this home a house.
是的。吉恩说那是他最喜欢的被删减的台词之一。哦，真的吗？嗯嗯。他喜欢那一刻。迈克尔继续试图安慰简，情况并没有好转，但这确实描绘了他对与她在一起的家庭生活的感受。你对简说了什么？亲爱的，小区里没人喜欢你，但你把这个地方弄得很好。这就像一个博物馆。你什么都不能碰，这在你住的地方感觉真的很奇怪。你把这个家变成了一所房子。
It's just what Paul Figue said about their design of the house, like a museum. You have made this warm, cozy home a house. Oh, Michael, I think they were right to leave those out because otherwise I think we might have felt too badly for Jan when Michael is about to do what he's about to do. But before we get there, Angela, I have to talk about this moment when Dwight offers you some of his beet salad and you respond by saying the thought of popping one of his beets into your mouth makes you want to vomit because I remember something else that was happening during this scene. Will you share it with us? Yeah, it was actually really hard for me to focus in this scene and say my dialogue because Jenna,
这正是保罗·费格所说的关于他们对房子的设计，就像一个博物馆。你把这个温暖、舒适的家变成了一所房子。哦，迈克尔，我想他们删掉这些是对的，否则我想当迈克尔即将做他要做的事情时，我们可能会对简感到太难过了。但在我们到达那里之前，安吉拉，我必须谈谈德怀特给你一些他的甜菜沙拉，而你回答说想到把他的甜菜放进嘴里就让你想呕吐的那一刻，因为我记得这一幕中还发生了别的事情。你能和我们分享一下吗？是的，实际上我很难在这一幕中集中注意力说出我的台词，因为珍娜，
my daughter in my belly just decided in that moment she was going to run a full marathon. She was like, digging, digging, digging, digging, digging, kicking so much. I don't know, maybe it's the sound of Rainn Wilson's voice. Maybe Rainn's voice awoken my child in my womb and she was ready to fight. But it was so surreal to me to be thinking about the timing of the scene and everyone's dialogue and when I was supposed to come in and trying not to laugh. In the meantime, having this like wrestling match happening in my belly. I think there are a lot of women who can relate to that, Angela. I have a friend who is a lawyer and she was very, very pregnant and she was having to take a deposition and she told me
我肚子里的女儿决定在那一刻跑一场全程马拉松。她就像在挖，挖，挖，挖，挖，踢得太厉害了。我不知道，也许是雷恩·威尔森声音的原因。也许雷恩的声音唤醒了我子宫里的孩子，她准备好战斗了。但对我来说，思考这一幕的时间安排和每个人的台词，以及我什么时候该进来，并试图不笑，这太超现实了。与此同时，我的肚子里还在进行这场摔跤比赛。我想有很多女性能感同身受，安吉拉。我有一个朋友是律师，她当时怀孕非常非常久了，她不得不进行证词陈述，她告诉我
at the end of the day she was like, I could barely focus on what I was doing because I was having to give very carefully worded questions and comments because it was all going on the record. But all the while her kid in her belly was just tossing and turning. Yeah, so much so and I have shared this story before and it's one of my favorite memories. While the scene was going on, I'm talking everyone is saying their lines and there's the rapid cadence of the dialogue. I, off camera, grabbed Ed's hand and under the table put it on my belly and he turned to me with his eyes wide and all of a sudden he wasn't Andy, he was Ed and he mouthed to me. Oh my gosh. I needed someone else to know and to witness like what I was like
在一天结束时，她说，我几乎无法专注于我在做什么，因为我不得不给出非常谨慎措辞的问题和评论，因为这一切都被记录在案。但与此同时，她肚子里的孩子一直在翻来覆去。是的，非常多，我以前分享过这个故事，这是我最喜欢的记忆之一。当这一幕发生时，我在说话，每个人都在说他们的台词，对话节奏很快。我，在镜头外，抓住了埃德的手，在桌子底下把它放在我的肚子上，他瞪大眼睛转向我，突然他不再是安迪，他是埃德，他对我做口型说。天哪。我需要别人知道并见证我当时正在经历的事情，
going through in the moment and it's such a special memory to me and when I rewatched the episode with my daughter, I said, Isabel, you were running a marathon in mommy's belly right now and she was like, what? It's so special to me. Guys, women are warriors. We go to work and we focus on our work as if we don't have that going on. Try to imagine how I could put it to a man like, okay, you're trying to give the most important presentation of your life and imagine a puppy is jumping at your leg the whole time. Like just the most distracting thing. Jumping at your leg, but it's inside you, which is even weirder. It's like the alien. What is happening? Women are warriors. Way to go, Ang. Beth Grant also shared her memories about shooting this
这对我来说是一个非常特别的记忆，当我带着女儿重看这一集时，我说，伊莎贝尔，你当时在妈妈肚子里跑马拉松，她说，什么？这对我来说太特别了。伙计们，女性是战士。我们去工作，我们专注于工作，就好像我们没有经历这些一样。试着想象一下我怎么能把它放在一个男人身上，比如，好吧，你正试图进行你一生中最重要的演讲，想象一只小狗一直在跳你的腿。就像最让人分心的事情。跳你的腿，但它在你里面，这更奇怪。就像外星人。发生了什么？女性是战士。干得好，安。贝丝·格兰特也分享了她拍摄这个
dinner table scene. Let's have a listen. Sitting at that table and, you know, sucking on those beats. The reason I was sucking on those beats was to keep from laughing and reigns over there. There's so much subtle humor in this episode and then, of course, the demented relationship that they have. I love you all so much. I'm so honored to be part of this very popular and respected episode. Each of you doing such beautiful, subtle, hilarious comedy. And I was so thrilled to see that all of you broke up too. Once we got inside and we sat down at the table and someone would break and say, sorry, sorry. And then someone else would break. Sorry, sorry. And then we'd keep going. The last thing I'll say is when I came home, I said,
餐桌场景的记忆。让我们听听。坐在那张桌子旁，你知道，吮吸那些甜菜。我吮吸那些甜菜的原因是为了不笑，雷恩在那边。这一集里有太多微妙的幽默，当然，还有他们那种疯狂的关系。我非常爱你们所有人。我很荣幸能参与这一集非常受欢迎和受人尊敬的剧集。你们每个人都做得如此美丽、微妙、搞笑的喜剧。我很高兴看到你们所有人都笑场了。一旦我们进去，我们坐在桌子旁，有人会笑场说，对不起，对不起。然后另一个人会笑场。对不起，对不起。然后我们继续。我要说的最后一件事是当我回家时，我说，
I do not know how Paul is going to edit this. It's too hilarious. Every moment is a three-hour episode. I don't understand how he's going to do it. But by golly, you did it. And it is just an honor to have been part of this amazing and, as I say again, demented episode. Amazing and demented. That sums it up. Yeah. Gene told me that he and Lee actually begged NBC to make this a supersized episode. But I guess the schedule had already been set. But he also told me that they did end up releasing a 29-minute producer's cut on iTunes that included a bunch of deleted scenes, including some of the ones we talked about, like the granola bar scene. Maybe NBC didn't supersize it because they were holding a grudge because Greg wanted it to go
我不知道保罗要怎么剪辑这个。太搞笑了。每一刻都是三个小时的剧集。我不明白他要怎么做。但天哪，你做到了。能参与这一集令人惊叹的，正如我再次所说，疯狂的剧集，真是我的荣幸。令人惊叹和疯狂。这总结了它。是的。吉恩告诉我，他和李实际上恳求NBC把这一集做成超长版。但我猜时间表已经定好了。但他还告诉我，他们最终确实在iTunes上发布了一个29分钟的制片人剪辑版，其中包括了一堆被删减的场景，包括我们谈到的一些，比如燕麦棒场景。也许NBC没有把它做成超长版是因为他们怀恨在心，因为格雷格想让它
as is. Wow. I love that speculation. They're like, no, you can have your weirdo episode, but it's only going to be 22 minutes. We're not going to make it big. That's what she said. One other little detail from this dinner party is how enormous the glasses were that Dwight was drinking from. To me, they look like glasses you buy at Spencer's Gifts. Remember that place in the mall where you could get kind of joke-sized stuff? Well, Paul really loved these glasses, and there was one detail about them he wanted to share with us. One of my favorite gags in the show is when Dwight comes over with his babysitter and they're at dinner with the wine glasses. I had them fill the wine all the way to the top because I figured
保持原样。哇。我喜欢这种猜测。他们就像，不，你可以有你的怪胎剧集，但它只有22分钟。我们不会把它做大。这就是她说的。关于这个晚宴的另一个小细节是德怀特喝水的杯子有多大。对我来说，它们看起来像你在斯宾塞礼品店买的杯子。还记得商场里那个可以买到那种笑话大小东西的地方吗？好吧，保罗真的很喜欢这些杯子，关于它们有一个细节他想和我们分享。我在剧中我最喜欢的恶作剧之一是德怀特带着他的保姆过来，他们和酒杯一起吃晚餐。我让他们把酒倒满，一直倒到顶部，因为我想
that's what Dwight would think you would do with a big wine glass is you would fill it right to the rim. So that's a little wine lover's joke for everybody. You know what they look like to me, Angela? They look like those wine glasses that I see a lot of moms post on Instagram about getting through their day. Wine weekend with the ladies and the wine glasses like the size of your head. Yes, that's what they remind me of. Yeah. Oh my god, lady, guess what? What? The food is ready. The food is ready, but it might be poisoned. Oh no. Oh my gosh, yes. Michael whispers to Pam. He thinks that Jan has maybe been trying to poison him. He can't prove it, but he thinks he just hopes she didn't do anything to the food tonight. Like
这就是德怀特认为你会用大酒杯做的事情，你会把它倒到边缘。所以这对每个人来说都是一个小小的爱酒人士的笑话。你知道它们对我来说看起来像什么吗，安吉拉？它们看起来像那些我经常在Instagram上看到妈妈们发的关于度过她们一天的酒杯。和女士们的葡萄酒周末，酒杯像你的头那么大。是的，这就是它们让我想起的样子。是的。哦，天哪，女士，猜猜怎么着？什么？食物准备好了。食物准备好了，但它可能有毒。哦，不。哦，天哪，是的。迈克尔对帕姆耳语。他认为简可能一直在试图毒死他。他无法证明，但他认为他只是希望她今晚没在食物里做什么。就像
what has been happening to Michael? Has he been having violent diarrhea, stomach cramping after he eats with her? Like what is making him think this? Pam has a talking head. Poor Pam is so hungry. She says she knows that Jan did not poison the food, but if she were going to poison the food, wouldn't she have poisoned Pam's since she is Michael's former lover? And now you know, Pam is not going to be able to eat. You guys, Michael has soft teeth. We learned that in this episode. And because of his soft teeth, he has to dip his meat into his wine or probably whatever beverage is in front of him. And Jan hates it. This has clearly come up before. And she doesn't want him to do it. She's like, could you stop doing it? It's disgusting.
迈克尔发生了什么？他在和她一起吃饭后是否有剧烈的腹泻、胃痉挛？是什么让他这么想？帕姆有一个谈话头。可怜的帕姆太饿了。她说她知道简没有在食物里下毒，但如果她要下毒，难道她不会毒死帕姆的吗，因为她是迈克尔的前情人？现在你知道了，帕姆将无法吃东西。伙计们，迈克尔有软牙。我们在这一集中学到了这一点。因为他的软牙，他必须把肉蘸进他的酒里，或者可能是他面前的任何饮料里。简讨厌它。这显然以前出现过。她不希望他这样做。她说，你能停止这样做吗？这太恶心了。
Lady, can I tell you a story about a guy I dated? Oh God, I was so worried you were about to tell me you dip meat into your beverages, but it's about a different, it's a guy. Angela, how long have you known me? You thought maybe I dip my meat in beverages? Well, you've made a face. You guys can't see her, but she made a face. You did the thing with your shoulders that you do, Jenna, when you're about to share something with me that you haven't shared before. And so I thought, oh my God, I've eaten with her, but have I ever eaten red meat with her? Oh my God. No, I eat meat normally. I can't believe that's a sentence I had to say. Well, but I did. No, what I was going to share was I dated a guy who first of all had to drink milk with every meal,
女士，我可以告诉你一个关于我约会过的一个男人的故事吗？哦，天哪，我太担心你要告诉我你把肉蘸进你的饮料里了，但这是关于另一个，是一个男人。安吉拉，你认识我多久了？你以为我可能把肉蘸进饮料里？好吧，你做了一个鬼脸。你们看不到她，但她做了一个鬼脸。你做了你肩膀上的那个动作，珍娜，当你准备和我分享一些你以前没分享过的事情时。所以我以为，哦，天哪，我和她一起吃过饭，但我吃过红肉吗？哦，天哪。不，我正常吃肉。我不敢相信那是我不得不说的一句话。好吧，但我确实说了。不，我要分享的是我约会过一个男人，首先他每顿饭都必须喝牛奶，
not water. Gross. He's a grown man, but he had to have a big tall glass of milk. I mean, maybe no judgment, but I'm just saying, I don't know. I judge. Okay, go on. We're at a restaurant, orders a tall glass of milk. But he had this thing where he would take a bite of food and then immediately take a sip of milk and then chew the food with the milk in his mouth and then swallow it. Oh, God. And you had to sit and watch that through a whole meal? This was his preferred way of eating. He liked the taste of his food mixed with a sip of milk. All foods? Every meal, every food, a bite of sandwich, sip of milk, a forkful of spaghetti, sip of milk. That is disgusting. That's a deal breaker for me. I can't spend the rest of my life watching you
不是水。恶心。他是一个成年男人，但他必须有一大杯牛奶。我的意思是，也许没有评判，但我只是说，我不知道。我评判。好吧，继续。我们在一家餐馆，点了一大杯牛奶。但他有一个习惯，他会咬一口食物，然后立即喝一口牛奶，然后嚼着嘴里有牛奶的食物，然后吞下去。哦，天哪。你不得不坐着看完整顿饭？这是他首选的进食方式。他喜欢他的食物混合着一口牛奶的味道。所有食物？每顿饭，每种食物，咬一口三明治，喝一口牛奶，叉一口意大利面，喝一口牛奶。这太恶心了。这对我来说是交易破坏者。我不能余生看着你
take one bite, a swig of milk and slosh it around. I can't do it. I'm out. I dated him a long time. How long? I don't want to say. Oh, no. Oh, no. But it was a lot of meals. A lot of milk meals. Yeah. Well, listen, Michael is really offended that Jan has pointed out this quirk in front of the dinner party and she is so evil. She goes, oops. And that's it. Michael has had it. He is going to take back his space. He marches off. We don't know where he's going or what he's getting. While he's gone, I got a little glimpse of your plate, Angela. Yeah. Will you please tell people what you did? You guys, it was one of those little actory moments and it might also have been because I was really pregnant and everything was smelling so strong to me,
咬一口，喝一口牛奶，然后在嘴里晃来晃去。我做不到。我出局了。我和他约会了很长时间。多久？我不想说。哦，不。哦，不。但那是很多顿饭。很多牛奶餐。是的。好吧，听着，迈克尔对简在晚宴前指出这个怪癖感到非常冒犯，她太邪恶了。她说，哎呀。就这样。迈克尔受够了。他要夺回他的空间。他大步走开。我们不知道他要去哪里或他要拿什么。当他离开时，我瞥了一眼你的盘子，安吉拉。是的。请告诉大家你做了什么？伙计们，那是那些小演员时刻之一，也可能是因为我怀孕了，一切对我来说闻起来都太强烈了，
but I took my napkin, my fancy napkin that Jan had laid out for all of us and I just gently covered my meat with it so I didn't have to look at it. And I thought Angela Martin would do that because she's a vegetarian. She wouldn't have eaten the meat or wanted to look at it, but she wasn't going to say anything because this is clearly not the dinner party where you want to voice up about the food. So I covered my meat with the napkin. So brilliant. I love that choice. Well, Michael comes back to the table and he has brought with him his neon beer sign and he takes a painting off the wall, which by the way, I want to point out is red. And he hangs up his beer sign and when the neon light goes on, you hear the hum and we are just bathed in this glow
但我拿了我的餐巾纸，简为我们所有人铺好的高级餐巾纸，我只是轻轻地盖住了我的肉，这样我就不必看它了。我想安吉拉·马丁会那样做，因为她是素食主义者。她不会吃肉或想看它，但她不会说什么，因为这显然不是你想对食物发表意见的晚宴。所以我用餐巾纸盖住了我的肉。太天才了。我喜欢那个选择。好吧，迈克尔回到桌子旁，他带来了他的霓虹啤酒标志，他从墙上取下一幅画，顺便说一句，我想指出它是红色的。他挂上他的啤酒标志，当霓虹灯亮起时，你听到嗡嗡声，我们只是沐浴在这个标志的
from this sign. Well, listen, it's a St. Pauli girl beer sign and it's outlined in blue. So when he turned it on, it was like a cascade of blue light filled the whole room. It's just so incredible. And you see the blue on Malora's face. That's how bright the light is. Jan is furious. She gets up, she turns on Hunter CD and now we are going to have the argument. Yeah, we thought we had the argument, but now the showdown is about to happen. Yeah, they start arguing about talent, about creativity. Michael's like, I don't think he's a good singer. I don't think he's very good at all, but Jan seems to love him. It's one of my favorite lines. Jan says at least he's an artist and Michael says BFD. I'm a screenwriter. And this is my favorite line. Jan says, and I'm a candle maker,
光芒中。好吧，听着，这是一个圣保利女孩啤酒标志，它是蓝色的轮廓。所以当他打开它时，就像一股蓝光倾泻而下，充满了整个房间。这太不可思议了。你可以看到马洛拉脸上的蓝色。灯光就是这么亮。简很愤怒。她站起来，打开亨特的CD，现在我们要吵架了。是的，我们以为我们吵过架了，但现在摊牌要发生了。是的，他们开始争论才华，关于创造力。迈克尔就像，我不认为他是一个好歌手。我不认为他很好，但简似乎很爱他。这是我最喜欢的台词之一。简说至少他是一个艺术家，迈克尔说BFD。我是一个编剧。这是我最喜欢的台词。简说，而我是一个蜡烛制造商，
but you don't hear me bragging about it. Yeah, it's one of my favorite lines of the whole episode. I also like this couplet. You burn it, you buy it. And then Michael says, great, I'll be your first customer. You're hardly my first. Oh my God, Angela, I cannot believe we got to sit in that room. I know. I mean, we got front row seats to this live show. It was mind blowing. Just the two of them were doing this dance and we got to watch it. I am still blown away that we got to be there. Well, when we asked Rainn Wilson about this episode, this is what he talked about. I think the true hero of Dinner Party is the magnificent Malora Hardin, who is insanely brilliant all through the series, but especially in that episode. I mean, Steve Carell being one of
但你没听我吹嘘它。是的，这是整集我最喜欢的台词之一。我也喜欢这一对。你烧了它，你就买了它。然后迈克尔说，太好了，我会成为你的第一个顾客。你几乎不是我的第一个。哦，天哪，安吉拉，我不敢相信我们能坐在那个房间里。我知道。我的意思是，我们得到了这场现场表演的前排座位。这太令人震惊了。他们两个在跳这支舞，我们得以观看。我仍然对我们能去那里感到震惊。好吧，当我们问雷恩·威尔森关于这一集时，这就是他谈到的。我认为《晚宴》的真正英雄是伟大的马洛拉·哈丁，她在整个系列中都非常出色，但特别是在那一集中。我的意思是，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是地球上
the all time greats on the planet Earth, comedic actors, and Malora Hardin stands toe to toe with him all the way through it being just as funny, just as specific, just as weird. And it's where you kind of see that Jan has turned a corner and that there is underneath this kind of external facade of blonde efficiency, there is a very, very weird egotistical, messed up human being under there. Her candles on and on, but her performance is just magnificent. It's so dry. It stands the test of time as just one of the great all time performances all throughout the series, but especially in that episode. When I rewatched it recently with my son, I was blown away by how great she was. Malora is the star of this episode. She just is. Yeah. We were so lucky to have her.
有史以来最伟大的喜剧演员之一，而马洛拉·哈丁在整个过程中与他并驾齐驱，同样有趣，同样具体，同样奇怪。这就是你看到简转折的地方，在金发效率的外表下，有一个非常、非常奇怪、自负、搞砸的人类。她的蜡烛还在继续，但她的表演简直太棒了。它太干了。它经受住了时间的考验，是整个系列中，特别是在那一集中，最伟大的表演之一。当我最近和我的儿子重看它时，她表现得有多好让我感到震惊。马洛拉是这一集的明星。她就是。是的。我们很幸运能拥有她。
I mean, back on the pilot when we cast her, could we have known that this is what was going to happen? Well, Jenna Malora has shared with us that she felt like they knew the chemistry these characters could have if they really got room to run way back on the pilot. Here's what she had to say. The whole Jan and Michael arc started when we were having lunch at the pilot episode, me and Steve and Greg were all having lunch together. Somehow, Steve and I both said there was just some spark and some weird dysfunctional attraction between Michael and Jan that if we ever got so lucky to make the series, we would hope that we could get them to hook up somehow, some way at some conference or something. That was the beginning of it. I think going into it,
我的意思是，回到试播集时我们选她，我们能知道会发生这种事吗？好吧，珍娜，马洛拉和我们分享说，她觉得如果他们真的有空间去发挥，他们知道这些角色在试播集时就能有这种化学反应。这是她要说的话。整个简和迈克尔的弧线始于我们在试播集吃午饭时，我和史蒂夫还有格雷格都在一起吃午饭。不知何故，史蒂夫和我都说迈克尔和简之间有一些火花和一些奇怪的功能失调的吸引力，如果我们有幸制作这个系列，我们希望我们能让他们在某个会议或其他什么地方以某种方式勾搭上。那就是它的开始。我想进入它，
I was always aware of what the potential for showing this wonderfully complicated and dysfunctional relationship was, the hilarity of that. It was just so funny and so dark, darkly funny, which just really appeals to my personal sensibilities. I really loved that the dinner party took it to that next step of implosion. Yeah, it was just thrilled. It was just thrilled that we had a chance to really implode on screen in front of everybody and hopefully get a lot of laughs out of it, which we did. Well, speaking of implosion, this whole thing is about to crescendo when Jan picks up a Dundee and smashes Michael's beloved plasma screen TV. Yeah, I mean, he's like, that was $200. Good luck paying me back on your $0 salary, babe. My favorite moment after that,
我一直意识到展示这种奇妙复杂和功能失调的关系的潜力，那种滑稽。它太有趣了，太黑暗了，黑暗地有趣，这真的吸引了我的个人感性。我真的很喜欢晚宴把它带到了内爆的下一步。是的，我只是很激动。我只是很激动我们有机会在所有人面前在屏幕上真正内爆，并希望从中得到很多笑声，我们确实做到了。好吧，说到内爆，当简拿起一个邓迪奖杯并砸碎迈克尔心爱的等离子电视时，这一切都要达到高潮了。是的，我的意思是，他就像，那是200美元。祝你在你0美元的薪水上还清我，宝贝。在那之后我最喜欢的时刻，
there's the silence of like, oh my God, what just happened? And the person that calls it for the night that's like, yeah, I'm done here is Melvina. She's like, yeah, I'm gonna go. Well, Melvina is the only person who doesn't work for this guy. So she could be like, yeah, I'm out of here. Yeah, this has taken a turn for me. Well, we had a fan question, Angela, from Meg, Emily, Ethan and Emma, how many plasma screen TVs were broken by a Dundee? And how many takes did this actually require? Well, I reached out to good old Kentopedia, who told me that those little TVs were actually kind of expensive. He said, they bought five of them, and we broke four. Oh, now I remember doing a bunch of takes with Melora, where she missed at first, and they would have us react as if she hit
有那种“天哪，刚才发生了什么”的沉默？而那个叫停这一晚的人，就像，是的，我在这里结束了，是梅尔维娜。她就像，是的，我要走了。好吧，梅尔维娜是唯一不为这个家伙工作的人。所以她可以像，是的，我离开这里。是的，这对我来说已经变了。好吧，我们有一个粉丝问题，安吉拉，来自梅格、艾米丽、伊森和艾玛，有多少台等离子电视被邓迪奖杯砸碎了？这实际上需要多少次拍摄？好吧，我联系了老朋友肯托百科，他告诉我那些小电视实际上有点贵。他说，他们买了五个，我们砸了四个。哦，现在我记得和马洛拉拍了很多次，她起初没打中，他们会让我们反应得好像她打中了
it. They could always use our reaction. But then she only had those five chances to actually land the Dundee when she was on camera. And you know, I mean, the sort of comical thing is, it wasn't a big target. It was. It's a small thing to hit square in the middle with a Dundee. It's true. Well, we're all going to follow Melvina out the door, right? Everyone gets up from the table. They're going to leave. I was actually asked not to get up from the table, if you notice. And it's because you would have seen my belly. So I'm the last to leave the dining room. Well, not only do we leave, but the police arrive. There are two moments that are so delicious in the scene. Well, one of my first things is right away, the police officers are like,
一样。他们总是可以使用我们的反应。但她只有那五次机会在镜头前真正打中邓迪奖杯。你知道，我的意思是，那种滑稽的事情是，它不是一个大目标。它是。用邓迪奖杯正中中心是一件很难打中的小事。这是真的。好吧，我们都要跟着梅尔维娜走出门口，对吧？每个人都从桌子旁站起来。他们要离开了。我实际上被要求不要从桌子旁站起来，如果你注意到了。这是因为你会看到我的肚子。所以我最后一个离开餐厅。好吧，我们不仅离开了，警察也到了。这一幕中有两个时刻太美味了。好吧，我的第一件事是警察立刻就像，
hey Dwight, because they know him because he's always hanging around them. He like wants to be part of the club. And the other thing is, is when Michael says to them, as if they know what he's talking about, he says, my girlfriend threw a Dundee at my TV. Yeah. Can you imagine? Well, they ask if he wants to press charges because some neighbors heard a lot of yelling, a big domestic disturbance. And Michael says, I'll take the fall. And they're like, no, I, there's, you're actually, you're actually not in fault. You don't have to take the fall. Is there anywhere you can go tonight? Yeah. And Dwight offers to take Michael home with him, which Michael refuses until he sees Jan come out of the condo. And then he's like, yeah, yeah, okay, no, I'll go home with you.
嘿德怀特，因为他们认识他，因为他总是和他们混在一起。他就像想成为俱乐部的一员。另一件事是，当迈克尔对他们说，好像他们知道他在说什么，他说，我的女朋友把一个邓迪奖杯扔向了我的电视。是的。你能想象吗？好吧，他们问他是否想提出指控，因为一些邻居听到了很多叫喊声，一场大的家庭纠纷。迈克尔说，我来承担责任。他们就像，不，我，有，你实际上，你实际上没有错。你不必承担责任。今晚有你可以去的地方吗？是的。德怀特主动提出带迈克尔回家，迈克尔拒绝了，直到他看到简从公寓里出来。然后他就像，是的，是的，好吧，我会和你一起回家。
Well, Jenna, as everyone is leaving, there was a Dwight and Angela deleted scene. And Angela is very sassy with Dwight. I want to play it. I noticed you're wearing open toed shoes. Since when did you become a whore? There might be a lot of things about me that shock you. Now, if you excuse me, I have to get back to my day. There might be a lot of things about me that shock you. And then I look them up and down. And I coyly kind of smile and I walk away. And now there's this series of scenes, right, that kind of wrap up the episode. There's a montage of Jan. She's trying to fix the Dundee. You can tell she's, she's sad. She, she knows this night went horrible. Clearly knows this is
好吧，珍娜，当每个人都离开时，有一个德怀特和安吉拉的被删减场景。安吉拉对德怀特非常无礼。我想播放它。我注意到你穿着露趾鞋。你什么时候变成妓女了？关于我可能有很多事情让你震惊。现在，如果你原谅我，我必须回到我的一天。关于我可能有很多事情让你震惊。然后我上下打量他。我害羞地笑了笑，然后走开了。现在有一系列场景，对吧，总结了这一集。有一个简的蒙太奇。她试图修理邓迪奖杯。你可以看出她，她很难过。她，她知道这一晚过得很糟糕。显然知道这是
a night they might not come back from, right? Yeah. You see Jim and Pam having this really cute scene. They finally got food. They're having a hamburger. Yes. We got a fan question about this from Regan Colliner who wants to know what burger place did Jim and Pam eat at the end because the burgers looked amazing. I'll tell you what, the burgers were amazing. I don't know if it was just because I'd spent four days saying I was hungry, but when I got that burger, I'm really eating it in that scene. I think you can tell. I think you were happy to eat anything other than that granola bar. I think I was. Well, we filmed that scene at the home plate burger joint and it was this little mom and pop hamburger stand, which eventually sadly went out of business.
一个他们可能回不来的夜晚，对吧？是的。你看到吉姆和帕姆有这一幕非常可爱的场景。他们终于得到了食物。他们在吃汉堡。是的。我们收到了一个关于这个的粉丝问题，来自里根·科林纳，他想知道吉姆和帕姆最后在哪个汉堡店吃的，因为汉堡看起来太棒了。我告诉你，汉堡太棒了。我不知道是不是因为我花了四天时间说我饿了，但当我得到那个汉堡时，我在那一幕中真的在吃它。我想你可以看出来。我想你很高兴吃除了那个燕麦棒以外的任何东西。我想我是。好吧，我们在本垒打汉堡店拍了那一幕，那是一个小夫妻店汉堡摊，后来不幸倒闭了。
It's now a smog shop. And in that same strip mall, there was a car wash that they turned into a cold stone creamery. And that is where Andy and Angela are sitting in the car having their ice cream. Yes. Ed and I have a very funny story about this moment. And I asked Ed, I texted him. I said, Ed, can I share about the car scene? And he's like, yes, you can tell everyone I farted in the car. So we're in the car and he's supposed to lick a little bit of my ice cream. And then I have to squish it on the side, right? It took a few tries to get that squish just right. And in between setting up, they'd have to clean the door and we're in between setups. And Ed had a little toot. And I was really pregnant, as you guys know. And it's, it smelled. And I was like, oh, no, oh, no.
它现在是一家烟雾店。在同一个购物中心，有一个洗车店，他们把它变成了冷石冰淇淋店。那就是安迪和安吉拉坐在车里吃冰淇淋的地方。是的。埃德和我关于这一刻有一个非常有趣的故事。我问埃德，我给他发了短信。我说，埃德，我可以分享关于车里的场景吗？他说，是的，你可以告诉大家我在车里放屁了。所以我们在车里，他应该舔一点我的冰淇淋。然后我必须把它挤在旁边，对吧？花了几次尝试才把那个挤压弄得恰到好处。在设置之间，他们不得不清理门，我们在设置之间。埃德放了一个小屁。我当时怀孕了，正如你们所知。而且它，闻起来。我就像，哦，不，哦，不。
And we were rolling when it happened. And so it's in the bloopers. Here it is. Here it is. Oh, God. Oh, God. Oh, no. Your vehicle is coming out of the car. I think I know what it is. I'm sorry. He drove you from the car. You had to get out. I had to get out of the car. And our crew was listening the whole time. And they're cracking up. Ed is hitting the dashboard like, no, no, come back. I'm sorry. It cracks us up. It makes me laugh. Oh my gosh. Years later, Jenna, when the show wrapped, Ed gave me the sweetest card. He wrote all of these lovely things. And he ended it with, and I farted in a car with you. So we'll always have that. Love it. It happens, guys. It happens. But that one made the blooper real.
我们拍摄时它发生了。所以它在花絮里。就在这里。就在这里。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。哦，不。你的车要从车里出来了。我想我知道那是什么。对不起。他把你从车里赶出来了。你不得不出去。我不得不下车。我们的工作人员一直在听。他们笑疯了。埃德拍打着仪表盘，就像，不，不，回来。对不起。它让我们笑。哦，天哪。多年后，珍娜，当剧集结束时，埃德给了我最甜蜜的卡片。他写了所有这些可爱的事情。他以“我在车里和你一起放屁了”结束。所以我们永远会有那个。喜欢它。它发生了，伙计们。它发生了。但那个进入了花絮。
Well, the very last scene is Dwight and Michael pulling up to this bus stop. And as they pass by, we could see that Dwight's babysitter is waiting for the bus with her cooler. And they do not offer her a ride. It's terrible. But Beth Grant sent in a little memory of shooting this as well. I must say, at the end, when I'm standing at the bus stop waiting for the bus, because he hasn't even had the decency to drive me home, and his car pulls up, and we have this moment of looking at each other, to me is so esoteric and brilliant and wonderful. And Reigns looked to me, and then he drives off the bus stop. He's a free man. I just love how tickled she is by her whole storyline in this. She was so game for all of it.
好吧，最后一幕是德怀特和迈克尔开车到这个公交车站。当他们经过时，我们可以看到德怀特的保姆正带着她的冷藏箱在等公交车。他们没有主动提出载她一程。这太糟糕了。但贝丝·格兰特也发来了一点拍摄这个的记忆。我必须说，最后，当我站在公交车站等公交车时，因为他甚至没有礼貌载我回家，他的车开过来，我们有这一刻看着对方，对我来说太深奥、太天才、太美妙了。雷恩看着我，然后他开车离开了公交车站。他是一个自由人。我只是喜欢她对她在这一集中的整个故事情节感到多么高兴。她对这一切都非常配合。
And I loved having her on set. She was an absolute delight. Yes. And Beth, oh my goodness, thank you so much for sending in these audio clips. And thank you to Malora, and Rain, and John, and Ed, and Paul Feig, Gene, and Lee, Kintopedia, Jenna, everyone really showed up for us for this episode. And Steve read the summary. Guys, that's dinner party. We hope you liked it. Angela and I worked extra long on this episode because we wanted to get everything we could and share it with you. This is one of our favorite memories of shooting the show, and we hope we did it justice. We love you guys so much. Thanks for listening. Go light your candles. Take a minute for yourself and find some serenity.
我喜欢她在片场。她绝对是一个快乐。是的。贝丝，哦，天哪，非常感谢你发来这些音频片段。也感谢马洛拉、雷恩、约翰、埃德、保罗·费格、吉恩和李、肯托百科、珍娜，每个人真的为这一集为我们出现了。史蒂夫读了总结。伙计们，这就是晚宴。我们希望你们喜欢它。安吉拉和我在这集上工作了额外长的时间，因为我们想得到我们能得到的一切并与你们分享。这是我们拍摄这部剧最喜欢的记忆之一，我们希望我们做到了公正。我们非常爱你们。谢谢收听。去点亮你的蜡烛。花点时间为自己，找到一些宁静。
Sam, will you take us out with just one night? Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
萨姆，你能用“只有一晚”带我们结束吗？感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是安斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需StitcherPremium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码Office。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。